I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们为你带来了“终极办公室重温”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妹。
Hello. Hi there! Oh we have an exciting episode today! Jenna has a real cute smile on her face you guys. Well today we're talking about vandalism. It is season nine episode fourteen written by Owen Ellickson and directed by my husband Lee Kirk who's here today! Hey, Lee. Yes, I am. Hello there, ladies. Hey.
大家好。嗨！哦，我们今天有一集精彩的节目！大家看，珍娜脸上带着灿烂的笑容。今天我们要聊的是“破坏公物”。这是第九季第十四集，由欧文·埃利克森编剧，由今天也来到现场的我的丈夫李·柯克执导！嘿，李。是的，正是在下。大家好，女士们。嘿。
It's so fun to have you in our studio. Yeah, this is pretty, it's, you know, it's pretty crazy to be at Season 9. You know, I mean, I've known for so long that this was coming. Yeah. When you guys started the podcast, I figured someday I'm going to be on there talking about vandalism, and it's crazy that we're here, so. It kind of is. It kind of went by just like that, didn't it?
很高兴你能来到我们的录音室。是的，这感觉真是，你知道的，来到第九季感觉太疯狂了。我知道，其实我早就知道这一天会到来。是的。当你们开始做这个播客时，我就想总有一天我会来这里聊聊“破坏公物”这一集，而现在我们真的坐在这里，感觉太疯狂了。确实有点。时间就这么一晃而过，不是吗？
It really did. Well, Lee, before we jump into our questions for you, would you like to hear a summary of your episode? I would, yes. It's my favorite thing. Okay, let's get into it. It's my favorite thing when Jenna goes, would you like to hear a summary?
真是这样。好了，李，在我们向你提问之前，你想听听你这一集的剧情梗概吗？我想听，是的。这是我最喜欢的部分。好吧，我们开始吧。每当珍娜问“你想听听剧情梗概吗”时，就是我最喜欢的时候。
She asks me every week and every week, I'm like, yes, I would. I don't know why. All right, here it is. Someone in the warehouse has vandalized Pam's mural. Pam enlists Nellie and Dwight's help to find and punish the vandal. Meanwhile, Angela and Oscar compete for the senator's affection at a donor party. And we get a glimpse of what life is like for Jim and Darryl as roommates in Philly. There's a lot of storylines to manage, Lee.
她每周都问，而每周我都回答：是的，我想听。我也不知道为什么。好吧，剧情是这样的：仓库里有人破坏了帕姆的壁画。帕姆请来内莉和德怀特的帮忙，想要找出并惩罚破坏者。与此同时，安吉拉和奥斯卡在一个捐赠派对上争夺参议员的喜爱。我们还能一窥吉姆和达里尔在费城做室友时的生活。李，这里面有很多故事线需要处理。
A lot of story going on there. Yeah, you were busy that week. I had a busy week, yeah. Well, listen, we always like to ask everyone, how did you get your job directing the office? Well, it started, I think, with a conversation that you had, right, with Greg. Yeah. You want me to tell that part? Well, you might as well. I guess so. It started there, right?
里面确实有很多故事在发展。是的，你那周很忙。我那周确实很忙。听着，我们总是喜欢问每个人，你是怎么得到《办公室》导演这份工作的？嗯，我想这始于你和格雷格的一次对话，对吧？是的。你想让我讲那一部分吗？好吧，你顺便讲讲吧。我想也是。一切都是从那里开始的，对吧？
I think so, yeah. Okay, so Greg called me into his office one day, and he had watched your movie that you wrote and directed that I starred in, The Giant Mechanical Man. And he just was going on and on about how much he loved it. He was really impressed, and he was so complimentary. It was just making me so proud. And then at the end of the conversation, he said, do you think Lee would like to direct an episode of The Office?
我想是的。好吧，有一天格雷格把我叫到他的办公室，他看过一部你编剧并执导、而我主演的电影《巨大机械人》。他一直在赞不绝口，说他有多喜欢这部电影。他印象深刻，赞誉有加。这让我感到非常骄傲。然后在谈话快结束时，他说：“你觉得李会想导演一集《办公室》吗？”
And then you pooped your pants. Because you're like, how fun. Yeah. And then you told me and I pooped my pants. Yeah, exactly. That was so cool of Greg to watch the movie, first of all. Yeah. And then to make that offer. And then I don't know if you remember what happened, but Ron Howard was slated to direct this episode, Vandalism, and I think a couple weeks before,
然后你吓尿了。因为你会想，这太有趣了。然后你告诉我，我也吓尿了。是的，完全是这样。首先，格雷格能看这部电影真的很酷。然后还提出了这个邀约。接着，我不知道你们是否还记得，罗恩·霍华德原本预定要执导这一集《破坏公物》，我想大概在几周前，
he had to drop out. I did not know that. Oh my gosh. Sorry you didn't get to work with Ron Howard, ladies, but you got me. Okay. So you filled in for Ron Howard. I filled in for Ron Howard.
他不得不退出。我不知道这件事。哦天哪。女士们，很遗憾你们没能和罗恩·霍华德合作，不过你们得到了我。好吧。所以你是顶替了罗恩·霍华德。我顶替了罗恩·霍华德。
I'm so glad it worked out, because it was such a fun week. You know, I took a picture that I just love, and I know it was really special for Jenna, but we were in the conference room and you were directing, and Jenna's kind of standing off to the side. It's when Pam has her big meeting, and I took a picture of you and her in the conference room,
我很高兴事情最后圆满完成了，因为那真是非常有趣的一周。你知道，我拍了一张我特别喜欢的照片，我知道这对我珍娜来说意义非凡，当时我们在会议室里，你在导演，而珍娜就站在一旁。那是帕姆开大会的场景，我拍下了你和她在会议室的照片，
and I'll share it in our stories because I just loved that you were on set. It was so fun. It was a really fun week. I had a blast. Okay, so here's question number two for you. How was your experience directing on the show? I mean, okay, first of all, when I've been asked that question before,
我会把它分享到我们的动态里，因为我太喜欢你当时在片场的样子了。那真的很有趣。那真是非常有趣的一周。我玩得超开心。好吧，给你的第二个问题是：你在剧中担任导演的体验如何？我是说，首先，以前当别人问我这个问题时，
I usually say something like, it's as if Greg Daniels handed me the keys to a Rolls Royce and said, you want to drive it down for a week. But actually a better analogy is, I'm going to give you guys a golf analogy. Oh, I love a golf analogy. Probably the first golf analogy that's been on the office, ladies, right? I think so. I think it might be.
我通常会说：这就好像格雷格·丹尼尔斯把一辆劳斯莱斯的钥匙交给我，然后说“你想开它兜风一个星期吗”。但其实一个更好的比喻是，我要给你们打个高尔夫球的比喻。哦，我喜欢高尔夫球的比喻。这可能是“办公室辣妹”播客里出现的第一个高尔夫球的比喻吧？我想是的。我想可能是的。
Yeah. So about 10 years ago, I don't know if you remember, Jenna, I went on a golf trip to this place called Bandon Dunes. It's in Oregon. It's an incredible golf course on the ocean. It's a Link-style golf course, so it looks like Scotland and it feels like Scotland. It's a very difficult course, right? I'm in. I don't play golf, but I'm in. It was amazing. It was an amazing trip.
差不多十年前，珍娜，我不知道你还记不记得，我去了一个叫班顿沙丘的地方进行高尔夫之旅。它在俄勒冈州。那是一个位于海边的不可思议的高尔夫球场。它是一个林克斯风格的高尔夫球场，所以看起来就像苏格兰，感觉也像苏格兰。这是一个非常难的球场，对吧？我加入。虽然我不打高尔夫，但我加入。太棒了。那是一次极其美妙的旅行。
Every golfer out there, you know, it's probably on their bucket list to go there. Anyway, I shot the best round of my life at Bandon Dunes. The hard golf course. The hard golf course, I broke 80, which for me is a huge accomplishment. Now, the reason I did that is because at Bandon Dunes, you don't ride in golf carts. You walk the course and you have a caddy who walks with you and sort of hands you your clubs,
对所有的球友来说，去那里大概都是他们的人生愿望清单之一吧。不管怎样，我在班顿沙丘打出了我人生中最好的一轮。在这个难打的高尔夫球场。在这个难打的高尔夫球场，我打出了低于80杆的成绩，对我来说这真是个巨大的成就。我之所以能做到这一点，是因为在班顿沙丘，你不能坐高尔夫球车。你必须步行走完全程，而且会有一个球童陪着你走，负责递给你球杆，
but also gives you advice. These caddies like know every corner of this golf course, right? This is like old school. Old school golf, right? Yeah. Well, I had this caddy, okay? This guy, this guy knew every nook and cranny of this course, okay? So we'd walk up to the ball, he would pull out a club, he'd hand me the club, he'd say, just swing 75% on this club, right? And
同时还会给你提供建议。这些球童对球场上的每个角落都了如指掌，对吧？这就像是老派风格。老派高尔夫，对吧？是的。嗯，我当时就有这么一个球童。这个家伙，这个家伙对这个球场的每个角落都熟门熟路。所以当我们走到球跟前时，他会抽出一根球杆递给我，然后说：“这杆只要用75%的力气挥就行了，”
he'd say, see that sand trap up there? There's a tree on the left side of it, aim at that tree. And I'm thinking, the green's way over the right. He's like, just do it. So I do, 75% at the tree, ball goes up, flies in there, turns a little bit, lands right before the green, rolls up, maybe 10 feet from the cup, right? Incredible, incredible shot. I'm shocked, we walk up on the green, same thing.
然后他说：“看到前面那个沙坑了吗？沙坑左边有一棵树，瞄准那棵树。”我心里想：果岭明显在右边很远啊。他说：“照做就行。”于是我照做了，用了75%的力气对准那棵树挥杆，球飞了出去，在空中转了一小下，刚好落在果岭前，然后滚了上去，距离球洞大概只有10英尺，对吧？难以置信，不可思议的一球。我很震惊，我们走到果岭上，情况也一样。
It's a difficult green, really fast, hard to read. He tells me, just tap it 30% right here, you know, and just right to the spot. I do it. It rolls. It goes in, right? Yeah. I'm feeling great. I shoot the best round of my life. Okay. Now that is like what it was like to be on the office because the office, I basically had like a hundred caddies. You know what I mean? I had like the incredible cast, the incredible crew, and all I had to do was like swing 75%. You know what I mean? Like I had to have a little bit, like with the golf, I had to have a little bit of knack for golf.
这是一个很难推的果岭，非常快，很难看懂线。他告诉我：“在这里轻轻推30%的力道就行，直接送到那个点。”我照做了。球滚了过去。进洞了，对吧？我感觉太棒了。我打出了人生中最好的一轮。现在，这就像是在《办公室》片场的感觉，因为在《办公室》里，我基本上有一百个球童。你知道我的意思吗？我拥有不可思议的演员阵容，不可思议的工作人员，我所要做的就是挥出75%的力气。懂我的意思吗？就像我得有一点点——就像打高尔夫一样——我得有一点点打高尔夫的天分。
Right, like you have skill. Had to have a little skill. Director, I had to have some skill as a director. I had to know what I wanted to do. I'd have made some decisions, but then everybody else made it so easy, you know? So it was a good time. I loved everything about that answer and now I wanna pick up golf.
没错，就像你有技术一样。得有一点技术。作为导演，我必须具备一些技术。我必须知道自己想做什么。我得做一些决定，但其他人把一切都变得太简单了，你知道吗？所以这是一段美好的时光。我喜欢这个回答里的一切，现在我都想开始学打高尔夫了。
So you do, not really. I'm like, only at that course. That course is pretty special. That course is pretty sweet. No, I can't mess up my tennis game, let's be real. Yeah, stick with tennis, you know. I just want you to make a golf movie now. I'm like, we should make a golf movie. Maybe that's my next movie. Yeah. Maybe it should be. Yeah, call it tennis, you know. I just want you to make a golf movie now. I'm like, we should make a golf movie.
你会去打的，其实也不会。我想说，只在那座球场打。那座球场确实挺特别的。那座球场相当赞。不，我可不能搞砸我的网球水平，说实话。是的，还是坚持打网球吧。我现在就想让你拍一部高尔夫电影。我觉得：我们应该拍一部高尔夫电影。也许那是我的下一部电影。是的。也许真该拍一部。对，叫它《球童》吧。《球童》。所以李，你曾经去过片场很多次。你一直在我们周围看拍摄。你甚至还在里面演过一个角色。
Maybe that's my next movie. Yeah. Maybe it should be. Yeah, call it The Caddy. The Caddy. So Lee, I mean, you had been on the set many times. You had been around us shooting. You even had a role.
你是那个哺乳顾问。我是克拉克。克拉克。没。所以，从导演的视角在片场呆过之后，你有没有获得什么新的见解？这是个好问题。你知道，情况是这样的：在此之前，我一直都在拍独立电影，对吧？
You were the lactation consultant. I was Clark. Clark. That's right. So did you gain any new insights from being on the set from the perspective as a director? That's a good question. You know, the thing is, okay, so I had directed indie films up to this point, right?
拍独立电影时，你们也知道，对于听众们来说，你只有20天或21天的时间来拍摄110页的剧本，进展非常快。通常第一遍拍得有点乱，然后导演的工作就是开始快速成型，通常第一遍拍得有点乱，然后导演的工作就是开始塑形，比如“也许别脱夹克，站起来走之前先深吸一口气”，然后你慢慢地把这场戏塑造出来。但与此同时你也很赶，你就像是在屏住
So an indie film, you're making the movie, you guys know this, but for your listeners, you have 20 days or 21 days to shoot 110 pages, you're moving really fast, you know, and usually the first time it's kind of messy, and then you start the job of the director is to kind of shape fast, you know, and usually the first time it's kind of messy, and then you start the job of the directors to kind of shape it, you know, like maybe don't take your jacket off and maybe take a breath before you stand up to go, you know, and slowly you kind of form this scene, you know, but at the same time you're rushing too, you know, you're like holding
呼吸。想象一下带着这种状态，然后我走进了《办公室》的片场。情况是这样的：我们会设置好一个镜头，我大概会告诉摄影指导马特·索恩——他是一个合作起来极其棒的人——我会说：“你知道，我希望他们也许从这里进来，我们在前台这里演这场戏，然后……”他会说：“太棒了，”我们打好灯光，你们来到片场，就像是你们手里拿着一杯咖啡走过来，
your breath. So take that and then I walk on the office, right? And so here's the experience. We would set up a shot, you know, and I'd kind of tell Matt Zone, who was the DP, who was just an incredible person to work with, I'd say, you know, I want to have maybe they come in over here and we play the scene at the reception and, you know, he's like, great, we light the scene, you guys come on set and it's like, you guys are walking on with like a cup of coffee
然后你们会问：“我们这幕拍什么？我们要干嘛？”然后你们拿到分镜头剧本，开始翻看。我心里就在想：我敢说他们自从围读剧本之后就没再看这幕戏了。你知道吗？你可能猜对了。到了第九季的时候。到了第九季，是的。我们真的会像是，
and you're like, what are we seeing, are we doing? You know, and then you get your sides and you're like look them over and I'm thinking, I'm not sure they've read the scene since the table read. You know? You might've been right. By season nine. By season nine, yeah. We would just truly, we would like be like,
我们现在在干嘛？是的。就像坐下来琢磨这幕戏到底是讲什么的。特别是如果我们没有大段的台词的话。如果你只是顺着走过前台，然后安吉拉说：“打扰一下，这就是我的全部台词吗？”是的，根本不需要太多准备。我打算等到了片场再临场发挥。
what are we doing right now? Yeah. Like sitting down wondering what is the scene? Especially if we didn't have huge chunks of dialogue. If you're just gonna cruise through a reception and Angela goes, excuse me, is that all I say? Yeah, not a lot of preparation for that. I'm gonna wait and just figure it out on set.
但有趣的是，事情就是这样发生的。然后每个人都在各自的位置上，我告诉你们：“哦，你们待会儿从这里进来，在前台这里演这场戏，巴拉巴拉……”好，我们试一条。Action（开始）。然后一场完美执行的戏就诞生了。就像所有东西——每个时刻都完美，每个笑话都完美，每个细微差别都完美。好，卡（Cut）。所有人都看着我，我得说点什么才行，对吧？除了“我们可以继续了”之外，你懂我的意思吗？除了“我们可以继续了”，你懂我的意思吗？所以这倒是个挑战。
But the funny thing is, so that's what happens, and then everybody in their place, I tell you guys, oh, you're gonna come in here, do this scene here, the reception, blah, blah, blah. Okay, let's try one. Action. And then a perfectly executed scene happens. Like everything, like every moment's perfect, every joke's perfect, every nuance perfect. Okay, cut. Everybody looks at me and it's like, I got to have something to say, you know what I mean? Besides just, we could move on, you know what I mean? Besides just, we could move on. You know what I mean? So that was a challenge.
这算是一个需要克服的挑战。当然，也有很多地方我实际上必须做一些导演的工作。但很大程度上就是这样。我的工作很大程度上是为这东西应该怎么运作建立一个愿景，然后就是保持大家的士气。保持好心情，让每个人都放松，尝试不同的镜头拍摄，并努力玩得开心。
Like, that was a challenge to find. Of course, there was a number of spots where, like, I had to actually do some directing. But a lot of it was that. A lot of it, my job was having a vision for how this thing should work. And then just kind of keeping everybody's spirits up. Being in a good mood, keeping everybody loose, you know, and trying different takes and trying to have fun.
但这跟拍独立电影有很大不同，拍独立电影时你得不停地看手表，压力巨大，你只想搞定一切，就是赶，赶，赶。是的，你整天担心拍不出来。而在这里，根本不用担心拍不出来。我感觉每一次第一条就能过。好了，李，我记得你曾跟我说过，你确实有一些想加入的想法，并且你跟马特·索恩讨论过。
But it was so much different than doing an indie film where you're just constantly looking at your watch, you know, and you're stressing and you're just trying to get, you know, Just a hustle, hustle, hustle. Yeah, and you're worried that you're not going to get it. You know, there was no worry we weren't going to get it. We got it on take one every time, I felt like. Well, Lee, I remember you telling me that you did have a few ideas that you wanted to throw in there that you talked to Matt Son about.
哦，是的。然后他不得不委婉地拒绝了你。哦，他太棒了。所以当我们第一次堪景时，你拿到了剧本，然后在拍摄前的一周左右，摄影指导和导演会一起巡视片场，看一看，并对拍摄会是什么样形成一个大概的想法。我对马特说，我有一个想法，因为我一直很喜欢老剧集里那种镜头，尤其是
Oh, yeah. And he kind of had to let you down gently. Oh, well, he was awesome. So when we first walked through, so you get your script and then like a week before you're shooting, the DP and the director kind of walk through the set and kind of look at and kind of have form an idea of what the shoot's gonna be like. And so I said to Matt I had this idea because I always loved on those old episodes especially
英国版的《办公室》，我想美国版里也这么用过。就在一个转场中，镜头直接切到一个复印机正在复印文件，或者就像某个人走过——给某人的办公桌送一份文件。那种安静的小镜头，能提醒你这是一部纪录片，对吧？所以我当时觉得，在其中加入这样一个镜头会很有趣，这将是我放进这一集里的小彩蛋。所以我对马特说，我很想拍一个这样的小镜头。他说：“嗯，你想拍什么都可以拍，但我向你保证，这绝对剪不进正片里。”
on the British office but they did I think I did it on the American too. Where just in a transition that you just cut to a copy machine just making copies or like just someone like walking across like delivering a piece of paper to someone's desk Just that little quiet shot that like reminds you this is a documentary, right? So I thought I'd be fun to put one of those in you know That would be my little Easter egg that I'm gonna put in this episode So I said to Matt I'd love to do one of these like little shots and he said Well, we could shoot whatever you want, but I can promise you that won't go in the episode.
因为他觉得——而且他是对的。根本没有时间。归根结底，剪辑师克莱尔和我，我们竭尽所能想把这一集的每一部分都保留下来。当然，那是不可能的。还有一个整条故事线，不，不能说是故事线，但有一个整整的……序列被剪掉了。不知道你们还记不记得，我们拍了一整段开车出行的戏。
Because he was like, and he was right. I mean, there was no time for it. And at the end of the day, you know, Claire and I, who is the editor, we were doing everything we could to keep every piece of that episode in there. And of course, that was impossible. And there's a whole storyline, there's a whole, not a storyline, but there's a whole, um, sequence that was cut, which was, I don't know if you remember, we did a whole driving sequence.
你们还记得吗？我记得，那在删减片段里。在删减片段里吗？对的。删减片段里还有一段关于托比的超搞笑的副线。哦，是的。等我们聊到那儿时我想分享一下。
Do you remember that? I do, it's in deleted scenes. Is it in deleted scenes? Okay. Yeah. And there's a whole runner with Toby that's hilarious in deleted scenes. Oh, yeah. Um, that I want to share when we get to it.
那是他在质询弗兰克时试图给内莉留下好印象。是的，没，我记得。我记得那段。是的，所以那倒挺好玩的。不过，我特别喜欢帕姆和德怀特组队的那些集。在这一集里，我记得在创作阶段——因为当时我在编剧室里——我就说：“我们能不能求求你们安排一场戏，
It's, it's, uh, he's trying to impress Nellie when he questions Frank. Yes, of course. I remember that. I remember that. Yeah. So that was fun though. Well, I absolutely loved episodes where Pam and Dwight got to team up. And on this episode, I remember in the crafting of it because I was in the writer's room, I was saying, could we please have a scene
让帕姆和德怀特进行一次秘密监视？”我希望他们……我不知道，安吉拉，这算不算早期“妈妈侦探”的一部分？是的。我当时就想要有这样一个时刻：他们在仓库里窥探每一个人。我只记得我们拍所有那些帕姆和德怀特的戏时都玩得超级开心。
where Pam and Dwight have, like, a stakeout? I wanted them... I don't know, Angela, if this is part of early mom detectives. It is. I wanted to have this moment where they were spying on everybody in the warehouse. And I just remember we had so much fun doing all those scenes, all the Pam Dwight scenes.
对，那些真的超级好玩。你们俩的……你们之间的化学反应，你知道的，帕姆和德怀特，看到这两个人组队真的太有趣了。里面有很多好玩的东西。关于那场戏我记得的一点是，在拍摄之前，有一场戏是你们俩
Yeah, those were a lot of fun. And you guys is just... Your chemistry and your, you know, the Pam and Dwight, like, seeing those two team up was just a lot of fun. And there was a lot of fun stuff. The one thing I remember about that was, in terms of directing was, before the scene, there's a scene where you guys
在监视仓库，德怀特拿着一副望远镜正在看，呃-huh。就在开拍前几分钟，道具师菲尔·谢伊——对，他走过来，拿给我两副不同的望远镜。真的吗，你知道会用哪一副吗？非常符合菲尔的风格。一副非常小，非常小的微型望远镜；另一副非常大，好吧。我在想，哦天哪，这可真是个考验，一副非常大，好吧。我在想，哦天哪，这可真是个考验，你知道的，这真是个考验。我当时觉得小的会挺滑稽的，因为我觉得那种他突然掏出一个东西结果小得离谱的场景会很搞笑。所以我说，就这——雷恩走到片场，
are spying on the warehouse and Dwight has a pair of binoculars he's looking through uh-huh so moments before Phil Shea the prop guy Yeah, he comes up to me, and he shows me two different binoculars It's the truth you know which ones would be using right very Phil one was very small Very small tiny binoculars, and one was very big okay, and I'm thinking oh man. This is a real test binoculars and one was very big. Okay, and I'm thinking oh man, this is a real test, you know This is a real test. I Thought the small ones would be funny because I thought it would be funny like kind of he whips something out and then it's like Ridiculously small. Yeah, so I said, oh these so rain walks on set
他看了看望远镜，问道：“还有别的吗？”菲尔说：“我有这种大号的。”然后他说——菲尔说：“我有这种大号的。”他说：“对，我就要大号的。”所以我没通过那个考验。哦不。好吧，你该知道的，我在片场给雷恩起了个外号叫胡萝卜顶（Carrot Top），因为他太喜欢带满满一后备箱的道具了。我当时就觉得，这人是真喜欢各种道具。
He looks at the binoculars. He goes is there another set of Phil goes I got these big ones. He's And Phil goes, I got these big ones. He's like, yeah, I want the big ones. So I failed that test. Oh no. Well, you should know, I nicknamed Rain on set Carrot Top because he loved a trunk full of props. I was like, the man loved a lot of props.
他会选夸张的大号望远镜，我一点也不意外。太棒了，太棒了。这么选也说得通。拍完之后我觉得：“哦，对，没错，我懂大号的妙处了。这挺搞笑的。”好吧。话说回来，你们拍吉姆和达里尔做奇葩室友的所有那些戏时，珍娜和我并不在场。吉姆和达里尔真是不称职的室友，
It's no surprise to me that he wanted the big over the top binoculars. Amazing, amazing. It made sense too. When we shot it, I was like, oh yeah, okay, I see the big ones. That's funny. All right. Well, Jen and I weren't there when you shot all of those scenes with Craig and John as horrible roommates. Jim and Daryl were such bad roommates,
但吉姆真是个邋遢鬼。我太喜欢所有这些戏了。我喜欢琢磨这两个人在剧里是怎么住在一起的。我们以前从没见过。我们甚至从未去过帕姆和吉姆的家去看看他们是怎么共同生活的。确实。我们只看过一点点德怀特和莫斯是怎么生活在一起的，但我特别喜欢看吉姆和达里尔。
but Jim is such a slob. I just loved all of these scenes. I loved thinking about how two people live together on the show. We never got to see that. We never even go into Pam and Jim's home and see how they live together. True. We saw a snippet of how Dwight and Moe's live together, but I loved seeing Jim and Daryl.
你们能跟我们讲讲拍摄那些公寓场景的经历吗？天哪，和约翰还有克雷格一起拍戏，我们玩得太嗨了。我敢说。我们太开心了。我们根本没法一条过。你知道，我们玩得太嗨了。我敢说。我们太开心了。我们根本没法一条过。你知道，我们一直在笑，在搞笑，
And can you tell us about shooting those apartment scenes? Man, shooting with John and Craig, we had such a blast. I bet. We had so much fun. We couldn't get through takes. You know, we were such a blast. I bet. We had so much fun. We couldn't get through takes. You know, we were just laughing and goofing off
玩得不亦乐乎。我记得我们在那个公寓里拍的第一场戏是达里尔午休回来，吉姆坐在那儿，达里尔拿着那个小保温箱。对，他把它打开了。他把它打开了。那个保温箱不知道怎么回事，天哪。
and having so much fun. I remember the first scene we shot in that apartment was when Daryl comes back on his lunch break and Jim is sitting there and Daryl's got that little cooler. Yeah, he opens it up. He opens it up. And there was something about that cooler, man.
他拿那个东西的姿势实在太搞笑了，我们根本没法正常拍完。我是说，他们根本演不下去。他们笑得太厉害了，我只能说：“好吧，卡。我们再来一次。”最后，这样根本行不通。所以最后我干脆由着他们了，你知道吗？让他们尽情地笑，笑个够，把笑意从身体里释放出来。但天哪，那真的，那真的太好玩了。
Something about the way he was holding that thing that we couldn't get through it. I mean, they couldn't get through it. They were laughing so hard and I would be like, okay, cut. And we'll try it again. And we finally, it wasn't working. So finally I just let them go, you know what I mean? Letting them just laugh and laugh and laugh and kind of laugh it out of themselves. But man, that was, that was so fun.
就像是一场绝对的狂欢。而且那两个家伙在一起太逗了。他们真的是在互相抛梗。就像你和雷恩一样，珍娜。你们俩之间也是，有一种非常奇妙有趣的化学反应。好吧，我记得你那天拍完戏回家时。很明显，你那一整天都跟那几个家伙“兄弟情深”去了。是的。你当时说：“他们太逗了。我们一直在笑。”但与此同时，我也记得你从参议员家拍完戏回家时——也就是和安吉拉、布赖恩还有奥斯卡一起拍的那场——你在那也玩得很开心。但我记得你跟我讲过其中的一个故事，你说那是整个拍摄中最具挑战性的时刻之一，这让我大吃一惊。
Like that was just a total blast. And those guys were so fun together. Like they were really working off each other. Same with you and Rain, Jenna. Like you guys were just like, there's such a fun chemistry going on there. Well, I remember you coming home from that shoot day. And it was very clear to me that you had just spent
哦，对，你是说那个婴儿。对，那个婴儿。所以这其实是独立电影制作的一个好例子，对吧？因为我们不是在片场拍的。我们在一个房子里。所以当你在片场拍戏时，场景怎么走位其实挺显而易见的，
the entire day broing out with those guys. Yeah. You were like, they're so funny. We just kept laughing. But then also, I remember you coming home from when you shot at the Senator's house with Angela Brian and Oscar, and you had a lot of fun at that too. But I remember you told me a story from that one where you said was one of the most challenging moments of the shoot, which took me by surprise.
因为每个人都有自己的位子。所以如果是安吉拉的戏，你知道你大概会在会计部那边，这就是你要拍的方式……你知道的。但在一个房子里拍摄，感觉就像是，从来没有人来过这里。而且我们有很多临时演员。所以这就包含了一种元素，那就是：好吧，
Well, yeah, you're talking about the baby. The baby, yeah. So this is actually a good example of more independent filmmaking, right? Because we weren't on the set. We were in a house. So like when you're shooting on the set, it was kind of obvious how scenes would be blocked out
我真的得好好导演这些东西。所以带有那个穿着白色洗礼服婴儿的戏，我记得当时在排练走位时我想：好吧，我们把它放在客厅。然后你们几个会以一种几乎像是登台亮相的方式出现，站得比所有人都稍微高一点点，
because everyone kind of had their spot. So if it was Angela's scene, you knew you'd probably be over and accounting and that's how you're going to, you know. But shooting in a house, it's like, no one's ever been here before. And we had a ton of extras. So there was this element of like, okay,
然后呈现这个时刻。我们就试一下。我们拍了，效果很好。挺不错的。我当时想：太棒了，我们再拍一条。就在那个时候，那个婴儿决定：我可不干这差事了。它一开始只是扭来扭去，接着就开始大哭大闹，发脾气了。
I really have to direct this stuff. So that scene with the baby in the little white communion outfit, I remember like staging that and I thought, okay, we'll put it in the living room. And then you guys would kind of appear as if you're almost presenting yourself standing up a little higher than everybody
我当时就想：哦，不，不，我们试着……能解决吗？你知道，还有别的婴儿吗？我们该怎么办？但没有别的婴儿，我们也无法解决。不过后来，鲁斯蒂——你们知道鲁斯蒂是谁，第一副导演——他对我说：“你知道吗，我们已经拍到了一条。”我当时说：“对，但那条好吗？”
and have this moment. And so let's try it. So we did it and it worked. It was fine. It was good. I was like, great, let's do another one. And around that time, that baby decided I'm not doing another one of these things. It started squirming at first and then just crying and having a fit.
他说：“我觉得挺不错的。”不管怎样，正片里用的就是那一条。第一条。唯一的一条。那是我们仅有的一次。所以。我还记得拍那张合影时我笑场了好多次，因为我回看时发现
And I was like, oh, no, no, like, let's try, can we fix this? You know, is there another baby? What are we gonna do? And there wasn't another baby and we couldn't fix it. But then Rusty, who was, you know, you guys know Rusty, the first AD, he said to me, you know, we got one take. And I was like, yeah, but is that good?
我和奥斯卡的台词根本不是剧本里写的。我猜也是。我有这种直觉。台词根本不是剧本写的。剧本里的实际内容是：安吉拉用手肘撞了奥斯卡一下，奥斯卡说“哎哟”，就这样。就这些。所以你看到的其他所有东西都是我们自己发挥的。
He's like, I think it was pretty good. Anyway, that is the take that's in the show. The first take. The only one. That's the only one we got. Yeah. So. I remember breaking quite a bit when we took the group photo because I was looking back
当我回看时，我看到自己在笑场。我当时把头低下去，因为太好笑了。太神奇了。是的。那真的太好玩了。太搞笑了。是的。真不敢相信我们居然把它拍完了。我知道。我也是。说到不敢相信我们能把事情搞定，
and none of our dialogue, me and Oscar's dialogue is scripted. I didn't think so. I had a suspicion. It dialogue is scripted. And I didn't think so. I had a suspicion. It's not scripted. And so literally what the script says is that Angela Elbow's Oscar, Oscar says, ow, that's it. That's it. So everything else you see is us.
我知道还有另外两场戏拍摄起来非常具有挑战性。对。李，你想分享一下吗？嗯，我们有布赖恩这个角色，他有几个重头戏。比如我们打架的那场。这需要一些动作编排才能设计好。我们有，你知道的，我们有那个扮演弗兰克的演员布拉德，他是个身材魁梧、极具压迫感的人。
And I, when I watched it, I see myself breaking. I like looked down and like, cause that was so fun. That's amazing. Yeah. That was really fun. That was really funny. Yeah. I'm surprised we got through that. I know. Me too. Well, speaking of being surprised we got through things,
所以要搞定那场戏确实有点挑战。而且布赖恩还拿着那些器材。哦，他拿着话筒杆。他拿着话筒杆之类的东西。他不能直接把它扔在地上。他得像那样，轻轻地把它放下。哦，对，我记得那段完整的对话。然后打斗，所以当时出现了一个奇怪的时刻，就像他必须……轻轻地把他的东西放下。哦，对，我记得那段完整的对话。然后打斗，所以当时出现了一个奇怪的时刻，
I know that there were two other scenes that were very challenging to shoot. Yeah. Lee, do you want to share? Well, we had the Brian character and he had a couple of big moments. So we had the fight, for example. That took some choreography to figure out. We we had, you know, and we had that actor, Brad, who played Frank, who was, you know, such a big, imposing figure.
就像他必须轻轻地把他的东西放下。所以这有点棘手，但最棘手的戏绝对是你们俩在那个储藏室里被发现的戏。是的。对吧？而在剧本里，我不记得具体是怎么表述的，但某种程度上它暗示了：
So to try to figure that out was a little bit of a challenge. And also, Brian had that equipment. Oh, he had the boom. He had the boom and stuff. He couldn't just throw it on the ground. Like, he had to kind of, like, gently set it down. Oh, yes, I remember that whole conversation. And then fight, so there was this weird moment of, like, he had to, like, gently put his stuff down. Oh yes, I remember that whole conversation. And then fight, so there was like this weird moment
我们在储藏室里有一场戏，然后你们离开储藏室，我们才意识到这个储藏室就在墙里面。情况正好相反。我回去重新读了剧本。剧本写的是我们穿过某个地方。它把那描述成一条通往这个小房间的走廊，然后到最后，我们走出去。有点像你说的，最后我们走出来，揭晓原来这是个储藏室。没错，是的。对，对。但我记得拍那场戏时，李，我和布赖恩进行的那段对话是边走边聊式的，就像一边走一边说：“我真的很抱歉，他们不该解雇你的。”你根本拍不出那种紧张感。
of like he had to like gently put his stuff down. So that was a little tricky, but the trickiest scene was definitely the reveal of you guys in that closet. Yes. Right? And so, and in the script, I don't remember exactly how it was worded, but somehow it alluded to like,
通过边走边聊的方式，你根本无法表现出那场戏的情感。而且进出那个地方，看起来真的很别扭。我们花了好久——天哪，我甚至不知道花了多少时间来琢磨那个。在想办法解决它。结果是欧文，编剧欧文，
we have a scene in the closet and then you guys leave the closet and we realize the closet is right in the wall. It was the opposite. I went back and I read the script. It was that we're walking through somewhere. It described it as like a hallway into this little room, and then at the end, we walk out. Kind of what you're saying, at the end we were to walk out and reveal that it was the closet. That's right, yes. Yeah, yeah. But I remember doing that scene, Lee, and the whole conversation with Brian, doing it like on the move, like walking and talking and me saying, I'm really sorry, they shouldn't have fired you. It was like you couldn't get any tension.
他想出了一个绝妙的主意，也就是我们最终采用的拍摄方式：我们把它拍得有点像偷拍镜头，然后镜头推进，这样你就看不出我们在哪里。作为观众，你只会看到地方，然后当你们离开时，我们拉开镜头，揭晓这个储藏室到底在哪里。我太喜欢这个安排了，因为当然了，那扇门对我们来说一直是个谜。每个人都好奇“那扇门后面是什么？”但你知道吗，这也是
You couldn't get any of the emotion of the scene by doing it as a walk and talk. And then getting in and out of there, it just was very awkward. And we spent, oh my God, I don't even know how much time trying to figure that out. Trying to figure it out. And it was Owen, the writer, Owen,
吉姆和帕姆勾搭上、也就是他们制造出菲利普的那扇门。是的，而且这也是我们在消防演习时想要逃跑的那扇门，虽然这根本说不通。是的，我们为此收到了一些粉丝来信。大家指出，为什么他们在这场火灾中会试图往储藏室里跑呢？所以。是的。所以当我们在夏天和年初与编剧们坐在一起，
who had the brilliant idea of how we ended up shooting it, which is that we shot it sort of as a spy shot and we pushed in so that you couldn't tell where we were. As a viewer, you would just see where, and then as you left, we pulled back and revealed where this closet was. I loved that because of course that door has been a mystery for us. Everyone know everyone's like what's behind that door? But you know it's also
讨论我们在最后一季里想要交代清楚哪些事情、想要揭晓哪些谜团时，我不记得是谁提出的这个想法了。我希望我能想起来，但有人说我们终于应该弄清楚那扇该死的门后面到底是什么了。我不记得是谁提出的这个想法了。我希望我能想起来，但有人说：我们终于应该弄清楚那扇该死的门后面到底是什么了。我太喜欢了。这太棒了。是的，所以我们让你们知道了。而且你当时也在场。
the door where Jim and Pam hook up where they made Philip. Yes and then also it's the door where we wanted to escape during the fire drill which does not make sense. Yes we got some fan mail about that actually. people noted why would they be trying to run into a closet during this fire? Yeah. So yeah. Yeah. So when we sat down kind of over the summer and the beginning of the year with the writers
我当时在场。大门谜底揭晓。我们做到了。我完成了开门揭秘。好了，李，在我们结束采访之前，乔什给我们做了柠檬玛德琳蛋糕。乔什。嘿。
to talk about what things do we want to tie up and what things do we want to reveal in this final season, I can't remember who pitched it. I wish I did, but someone said we should finally find out what's behind that dang door. I can't remember who pitched it. I wish I did, but someone said, we should finally find out what's behind that dang door. I love that. That's amazing. Yeah, so we let you know. And you were there.
乔什是个绝佳的烘焙高手。我不能不把它拿出来。所以，就是这样。今天每个人都有柠檬玛德琳吃。这太棒了。现在我们俩的老公都在这儿了。他们确实都在。谢谢你，乔什。
I was there. The big door reveals. We made it happen. I did the door reveal. Well, Lee, before we wrap up our interview, Josh made lemon madeleines for us. Josh. Hey.
乔什扔出了他的玛德琳蛋糕，而李就 literalmente（字面意义上）坐在这里。 literalmente 坐在这儿。对，正在吃玛德琳。是的，完全如此。好吧，李，在你离开前做个总结，相比电影，你觉得电视剧导演当得怎么样？从那以后你再也没导演过电视剧了。是因为你讨厌它吗？
Josh is such a good baker. I can't not bring them out. So there you go. Everyone gets lemon madeleines today. This is nice. This is now both our husbands are here. They are. Thank you, Josh.
不。嗯，其实，其实我挺喜欢的。嗯，我不知道你们还记不记得当时发生了什么……对。所以当时我导演了这一集，我爱死它了。我太喜欢了。太有趣了。我当时想：哦，我或许还想多拍一些这种。也许你不想跟拍独立电影那种压力山大的状态绑在一起了。我想多拍一些这种一切都按部就班的。是的。
Josh threw his madeleines and Lee literally here. Literally sitting here. Yeah. Eating a madeleine. Yes, exactly. Well, Lee, to wrap things up before you go, how did you like directing television versus movies? You have not directed any more television since. Is that because you hated it?
所以我记得我开过一些会议，讨论过执导《杰茜驾到》或者《神烦警探》的可能性，但当时它们还没开拍。所以那还在计划中。但接着我拍了一部电影。拍完电影后，我们搬到了伦敦。记得吗？是的，我在那儿拍了一部剧，而你在伦敦剪辑了那部电影。在伦敦。所以当我最终回到洛杉矶时，
No. Well, actually, actually, I loved it. Well, I don't know if you remember what happened, but... Yeah. So I directed this episode and I loved it. I loved it. It was so fun. And I thought, oh, I want to maybe do some more of this. Maybe you don't want to be attached to your stressful watch doing the independent films. I wanted to do more of these where you just kind of keep it on the rails. Yeah.
已经是大约一年后了，你知道吗？《办公室》已经不在播出了。而福克斯的那些高管也不在那儿了。我差不多错失了我的时机。这很难，这是一份很难得到的工作，比如电视剧导演的工作，仅仅是成为那名电视剧导演。所以我差不多错失了时机，这真是一个遗憾，你知道吗？这真是一个遗憾。
And so I remember I had some meetings about maybe doing New Girl, maybe doing Brooklyn Nine-Nine, but they weren't shooting then. And so that was on the horizon. But then I went off and made a film. And then after I made the film, we moved to London. Remember? Yes, I did a series there and you edited the film in London. In London. So by the time I finally came back to LA,
所以我想，如果外面的哪位，如果你预定了罗恩·霍华德但他的档期排不开，你知道该给谁打电话。我们当然知道。好吧，我告诉你一件事。如果“妈妈侦探”真的拍成了，你知道该给谁打电话。我们当然知道。好吧，我告诉你一件事，如果“妈妈侦探”真的拍成了，就这么定了。你就是我们的导演。
it was like a year later, you know? And the office wasn't on the air anymore. And those execs weren't at Fox anymore. And I kind of missed my moment. Like it's hard, it's a very hard job to get, like a TV directing job, just to be that TV director. And so I kind of missed my moment and it's a regret, you know? It's a regret.
好的，太棒了。是的，没问题。对吧？没错。我们会玩得超开心。我太乐意了。好吧，我们知道他擅长拍监视戏，而“妈妈侦探”里有很多这样的戏。
So I guess if anyone out there, if you got Ron Howard tapped up and he can't do it, you know who to call. We sure do. Well, let me tell you something. If Mom Detectives ever happens, you're who to call. We sure do. Well, let me tell you something, if Mom Detectives ever happens, There we go. You're our director.
没错，没错。我已经体验过挑选望远镜和所有这些了。好吧，你刚刚自己坦白了你没挑对。所以我们会把这一点考虑进去的。把那段删掉吧。我们会把那部分剪掉的。哦，李，谢谢你来作客。
Okay, very good. Yes, for sure. Right? That's right. We'd have so much fun. I would love that. Well, we know he's good at shooting stakeouts and there are a lot of those in Mom Detectives.
有你在这里太好玩了。太好玩了，大家。谢谢你们邀请我。太带劲了。能跟你们坐在这间小房子里聊天太开心了。非常感谢你，李。我爱你，老兄。我要来个拥抱。
Exactly, exactly. I've experienced picking binoculars and everything. Well, you did just confess you didn't pick the right ones. So we will take that into consideration. Let's delete that. We'll take that part out. Aw, Lee, thank you for coming in.
哦，耶。好吧，那我们休息一下，跟李道别。我可能会在出门时顺便给他一个吻。好吧。然后我们回来继续剖析剩下的“破坏公物”这集。我要去吃个玛德琳。刚才多有意思啊。我在停车场逗留了一会儿。你离开了一会儿。
It was so fun to have you here. So fun, y'all. Thank you for having me. What a blast. It's so fun to sit in this little room with you guys. Thank you so much, Lee. I love you, buddy. I'm coming in for a hug.
他长得也挺帅的，各位。他是个小帅哥。确实。而且我只是觉得，这就像是你可以带你的爱人去上班。哦，天哪。现在你变成托比了。我不知道我刚才为什么要这么说。现在你变成托比了。
Aw, yeah. All right, well, we'll take a break and we'll say goodbye to Lee. I might give him a smooch on the way out the door. All right. And then we'll be back to break down the rest of vandalism. I'm going to eat him out of line. How fun was that? I did linger in the parking lot. You were gone for a bit.
哦不，对不起。哦，你对我们“托比”了一把。好吧，我们开始讲这一集吧。它将从一个开场小品开始。内莉好像找不到达里尔，埃琳则是一副“你知道吗？他就在这儿附近的某个地方，这就是个普通的周四”的样子。埃琳很高兴，她的行为有点比平时更奇怪。
He's very handsome as well, everyone. He's a cutie. He is. And I just, it was like you get to bring your lover to work. Oh, oh gosh. Now you're Toby. I don't know why I did it. Now you're Toby.
大家，他真的很帅。他是个小可爱，真的是。我当时就觉得，这就像是你能带恋人去上班一样。噢，噢天哪。现在你是托比了。我不知道我为什么这么做。现在你是托比了。
Oh no, I'm sorry. Oh, you Toby'd us. Well, let's start this episode. It's going to begin with a cold open. Nellie can't seem to find Daryl, and Aaron's like, you know what? He's around here somewhere, just a regular Thursday. Aaron is giddy, she's acting kind of stranger than normal.
噢不，对不起。噢，你把我们托比化了。好吧，我们开始这集吧。它将以冷场开场。耐莉好像找不到达里尔，而艾琳却说，你知道吗？他就在这附近某处，只是一个普通的周四。艾琳欣喜若狂，她的举止比平时有些诡异。
And we find out that in her mind, she's helping Daryl pull off his whole secret other job. Yes, it's their big sneaky sneak. Sneaky sneaks. Part of this ruse involves a giant bear named Barrel. It wears a shirt and she sets it in his chair in his office. Yes, I want to point out that we did have a secret conversation in the place where all secret conversations happen.
我们发现，在她心里，她正在帮达里尔进行他的秘密兼职。是的，这是他们的大秘密行动。秘密行动。这个诡计的一部分涉及一个名叫巴里尔的巨型熊。它穿着衬衫，她把它放在他办公室的椅子上。是的，我想指出的是，我们确实在所有秘密对话发生的地方进行了一次秘密对话。
The super secret stairwell. That's right. The super secret stairwell for Sneaky Sneaks. There it is. Yeah. We had a fan question from Lee M. in San Jose who said, it looks like there's a piece of painter's tape on the back of Darryl's jacket in the scene in the stairwell. What is this? Lee M. I looked at it and you know
超级秘密楼梯间。没。错。给秘密行动准备的超级秘密楼梯间。就是这样。对。我们收到了来自圣何塞的李·M的粉丝提问，他说，在楼梯间的场景中，达里尔夹克背面似乎有一块油漆工胶带。这是什么？李·M。我看了看，你知道
what it is? It's actually a blue strap guard for his shoulder bag. Oh, yeah. I zoomed in. It's just a little something I like to do for people. This maybe has been bothering Lee M. for a while. Yeah, you do the zoom in. I did. We also had a fan catch from Patrick K in Spring, Texas and Catherine H in Somerset, UK. I think maybe they did a zoom in because they said, around the 30 second mark, Erin is doing jumping jacks
那是什么吗？其实那是他单肩包的蓝色肩带护垫。噢，是的。我放大了看。这只是我喜欢为粉丝做的一点小事。这可能已经困扰李·M一段时间了。是的，你做了放大处理。我是做了。我们还收到了来自德克萨斯州斯普林市的帕特里克·K和英国萨默塞特郡的凯瑟琳·H的粉丝发现。我想他们可能也放大了，因为他们说，在大约30秒的时候，艾琳在做开合跳
to distract everyone around the reception area. I know, I know, I know, I know, I know. What is it? What is it? I'm the reception area. I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know. What is it? What is it? I'm quoting Dwight. I know, I know, I know. It's your Uggs. Well before that. What? There's a double catch. What was the other one?
来分散前台周围所有人的注意力。我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道。是什么？是什么？我在前台区域。我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道。是什么？是什么？我是在引用德怀特的台词。我知道，我知道，我知道。是你的雪地靴。在那之前。什么？有两个发现。另一个是什么？
Uggs was one of them. I saw Uggs. Okay. They said Pam clearly isn't at her desk in those shots, but then at 35 seconds, Pam is at her desk and is wearing Uggs. Oh. So maybe we didn't think I would be in the frame and I was, maybe I was late to set. Or maybe they added you last minute.
雪地靴是其中之一。我看到了雪地靴。好吧。他们说帕姆在那些镜头里明显不在她的桌子旁，但在35秒时，帕姆在她的桌子旁，而且穿着雪地靴。噢。所以也许我们没料到我会入镜，而我确实入镜了，也许我到片场迟到了。或者也许他们是最后一分钟把你加进去的。
True. Many options here, but they all end in the fact that you had on your Uggs. Yes, I clearly didn't have time to put on my shoes. So Angela, you reached out to the writer of this episode, Owen Alexen. I did. You know, Owen is such a wonderful person and we reconnected at Phil Shea's memorial and got to talk for a while and I told him this episode was coming up for us and he said he'd love to contribute.
真的。这里有很多可能，但它们都有一个共同的结果，那就是你穿着雪地靴。是的，我显然没有时间穿鞋。所以，安吉拉，你联系了这集的编剧欧文·阿莱克森。是的。你知道，欧文是个非常棒的人，我们在菲尔·谢的追悼会上重新联系上了，聊了好一会儿，我告诉他我们快要讲到这一集了，他说他很乐意做出贡献。
So we sent Owen a few questions and we're going to share some of his answers throughout the episode. Jenna, you want to kick us off? Sure. One of the first things he said was how much he loved shooting Daryl's talking head in this cold open. Yeah. He said that saying sneaky sneaks would just crack them up. That every time Craig said sneaky sneaks. He even said in his email, just typing out sneaky sneaks is making me laugh. And you know what? Now I kind of love saying it. Me too.
Finally, for this cold open, we got a fan question from Alexandra T. in Los Angeles, California, who wanted to know how did we get Beryl to slowly fall off the chair? The timing was amazing. You know, that shot through the blinds. Oh yeah. I'll tell you, Alexandra, we had a crew member sitting on the floor, and they were pulling on the bear with one of those, like, filament wires, one of those little invisible strings that magicians use.
That's how Beryl fell over. It was perfect. Before we dive into the meat of the episode... The meat of the episode? Sure. Why not? The meat of the episode. I have a call sheet tidbit and a meat of the episode? Sure. Why not? The meat of the episode. I have a call sheet tidbit and a quote of the day from my digital clutter. Whoa. Okay. Uh-huh. I've been real excited. You are real excited. I am real excited. First of all, per the call
sheet, we filmed this episode the week of December 10th, 2012. And here's your weather report. The week started with partly cloudy skies and a high of 72. And halfway through production, we were dealing with rain and highs in the 50s. That sounds like December in LA. It does. But you know, I always love that Steve Burgess sends us the call sheets, Jenna. And I immediately look at the date that we started filming and I go to my digital clutter every week. And sometimes there clutter every week and sometimes there's
something there, sometimes there's not, and there was a delicious nugget for this week. A quote of the day. Quote of the day. On Thursday, December 13th, 2012, I had an exchange with Oscar Nunez and I emailed you about it, Jenna. Okay. I wrote the following. So we're in here in makeup right now. We are talking about movies, Jenna. Okay. I wrote the following. So, we're in here in makeup right now.
We are talking about movies, et cetera. Oscar recently saw Finding a Friend for the End of the World. He said he liked the movie, and then he sighed and said, Steve, man, he gets to make out with Keira Knightley and Anne Hathaway. I get f***ing Jack Coleman.
We all burst out laughing. And you wrote back, ha ha ha. Oh my goodness. Oh, that is very funny. That's my digital clutter quote of the day. Well, let's get back to the episode. Let's begin. We're gonna start with a Pam talking head.
She says she's putting in a lot of hours on this mural and her boss is okay with it because guess what? He's in the Bahamas. Yes, this was a talking head on the move. A lot went into this. I remember setting up this scene. There was originally this scene where I was in the parking lot
and I was talking on the phone to Jim. Yeah, it was in deleted scenes. It was kind of like a flirty conversation where Jim's like, you come here this weekend and you're like, I'm busy. You come here. Yes. Like that. It was like, who's going to visit who? Right. So then we were going to cut to Pam doing this talking head in the warehouse. And it
was originally supposed to be Pam standing kind of with her back to the mural talking about how excited she was to work on it. And then the camera would pan up and we would see the graffiti and Pam would freak out. Okay. The problem with that was when we got in place, we realized Pam would have seen the vandalism as soon as she walked into the warehouse. Yeah. How could you miss it? How could she miss it? So Lee said, why don't we do this talking head on the move so that when she gets to the end of her talking head, she's just coming around the corner of the warehouse shelves
and then she sees the vandalism and the camera swings up to see it too. And we were like, yes, that's great. But timing it out exactly perfectly was a little tricky. So what we did was I stood in the spot where I needed to be to realize it. And then I said my lines and we backed up. And then that was our starting position.
I don't know why I remember that so vividly, but I think it's just because it's the first time that like me and a whole camera crew went backwards. Yeah. Well, let's talk about what was on the mural. It's a whole bunch of big old butts. Yeah. And the words, this sucks. Oh yeah, there's that.
It's so mean. It's really aggressive. We had a fan question from Bailey H. in Overland Park, Kansas who said, was the shape painted on Pam's mural always scripted to be butts?' I feel like a different shape is more common in graffiti, but maybe it wouldn't pass standards and practices without a whole lot of blurs."
So Bailey, this scene really evolved through many drafts. In the table read draft, the graffiti was described like this. Quote, "'The mural is now covered in splashes of red paint, crude drawings, and a few messages like, this sucks, and he day rules. Mm-hmm. And then when Pam entered, Val was going to apologize to her
and say, I'm just seeing this myself. I think the guys got drunk last night and did it. So that was like the original moment. say, I'm just seeing this myself. I think the guys got drunk last night and did it. So that was like the original moment. Then in the original shooting graph, it was described like this, quote, the mural now has some obvious striking graffiti on it. There are a couple of crudely drawn butts and someone has written this sucks. And then they took out that extra part with Val. And Bailey, standards and practices did have notes on this. I bet. Here is what they said.
They said, the crudely painted butts on the wall should not be lifelike in appearance. Lifelike. Yes, very cartoony. Can't be too realistic. Exactly. Well, you know, I asked our writer, Owen, was it always the plan for Pam's mural to be vandalized?
And here's what he had to say. He said he didn't think it was always the plan. It started as a way for Pam to flex her art muscles at work. But then when they started the storyline with Brian the Boom Guy, they wanted to create an intense situation for Pam that he could help her with so the fight over the mural fit right in. Yes, you know, and it's interesting. I remember being in these discussions because,
you know, a big question when we decided on this storyline was, well, who did it? Right, because whoever did it is gonna get fired. And we kind of thought, like, oh, He-Day had been giving Pam grief when she was painting. Maybe it's him. Can I say in defense of Hide, not so much grief as just like,
like, hey, get started. He had like critiques. He had thoughts. He did. But it wasn't so much like he was not a fan of what she was doing. He just had a lot of opinions about it. Yes, but we didn't want to fire Hiday. Of course not.
So we did that kind of sneaky sneak thing where we're like, I guess we'll reveal a new warehouse worker who will be responsible for this. That's how they came up with the character of Frank. But another thing was that later we knew that Frank and Brian were going to fight it out. Yeah. And, you know, Brian the boom guy was like a kind of big muscly guy. And we didn't want him to beat up Hiday. That didn't seem, also Hiday didn't seem like a person who would like throw punches over
this right? No, Hiday's not gonna charge Pam. No. I think Hiday actually likes Pam. He just has opinions about her art like I said. But I totally see in casting that you needed someone big who looked intimidating if they were going to run at you. Exactly. I mean, we'll get to it. We're a little ahead of ourselves.
Yeah, we'll get to it. But this is everything that went into like the discussion of this storyline. Right. Speaking of Hideo, I have the cutest thing to share with you. What is it? So, you know, we just had that eclipse, right? Yeah. And I was talking about it in my Insta stories about the path of totality and all of that,
because I love that title. Like, they said it so many times, the path of totality. Are you in the path of totality? I was like, this should be a movie. Yeah. Right? This should be a rom-com called The Path of Totality. But anyway, I was going on and on about it and
then a few people sent me pictures they took of the eclipse and Hide sent me a video that he took of the eclipse. What? Yeah. I was like Hide, this is amazing. And he was like, thank you. Yeah, but he wasn't in the path of totality, right? He was a partial. He was in partial here in California. We got partial, but he still sent me his video of it. Look, here it is.
Oh it's really good. It's cool isn't it? I don't even understand how he got that. All right well next up Angela enters simply to announce that she'll be leaving. Yes. Basically you've come to work to tell us you're leaving early. You're so proud. I'm so proud. I'm so dressed up. I'm ready for a very fancy day real quick at one minute 53 seconds We have a new Meredith wig. It is a dirty blonde. I would say a mullet I think this is a mullet. It is mullet like yes Yes Angela is gonna go on to tell everyone that it's Phillips first birthday and they're hosting a party at their house
Erin says oh cute soul. There'll be a bunch of kids. And Angela says, oh no, no children. Our house is not kid friendly. Most of our furniture is sharp. Also, ew, it will be mostly campaign donors. Ange? Mm-hmm? We got a lot of fan mail about your hair.
Oh really? Particularly from Hannah H. in Cleveland, Ohio, who said, Angela, your hair is drop-dead gorgeous in this episode. Hannah! Would love to hear how this hairstyle was decided upon. Oh my gosh, Hannah, you just made my day. Drop-dead gorgeous.
You know, this was so fun for Kim and I. Kim Ferry, who did my hair on the show, we knew we wanted a half up half down, but she wanted to do something fancy. Kim is phenomenal with hair. And so she was like, what about a little swirly thing in the back and then we'll flip it up? This was all Kim's vision. She had a total vision for it. I said, just go for it, Kim. I'm here.
I am your canvas. And then I got to go have a costume fitting and they paired it with this dress and it just all came together. You know, I always felt bad for Kim Ferry because she was forced to do this just kind of boring everyday hair on all of us. Oh yeah. All the time. Nothing ever fancy.
And so when it came along. Oh my gosh. And because also she is so good at the fancy hair. Yeah. She is so good at an updo. She is so good at a vent hair. Yeah. She is so good at an updo. She is so good at a vent hair. Like, if you need someone to zhuzhu for your wedding, she's your gal.
Or a red carpet. Like, ah, so for her to just have to do low ponies every week. I know, or just a flat iron. Exactly. So yeah, that was a lot of fun, Hannah. Thank you. Well, guess what?
Oscar has a talking head and he's going to reveal that he will be attending this party. Yeah. Oscar says, Angela's husband and I are in love, but as a politician in this town, you still need the conventional blonde wife on your lawn signs. And then he's very proud. He goes, he is risking everything to have me there today. Me. Well, Angela's going to call Robert. Guess where she's at? The sneaky sneak stairway?
The secret sneaky sneak stairwell. She says, Robert, we agreed that you wouldn't be seen with him in public. It's humiliating for me. You know what? If you get to bring a stud, maybe I do too. Next we're going to go to Jim and Daryl's apartment. Jim is eating some cereal in the kitchen. He's just, like, leaning against the counter. He's not sitting at a table. Daryl's going to enter. And they have a joint talking head,
where they say, we're sharing a sublet in Philly. Yeah, they're grown, sexy-ass roommates. And Jim says, you know, I miss Pam and the kids, but I'm really enjoying letting my hair down and living single life. Excuse me, you're not single, Jim. Oh, you know what though, Pam's the bad guy. So, yeah. We also find out that Daryl is the clean one and Jim is the messy one. Yeah. We had a fan question from Clara D. in Germany who asked, I think the storyline of Jim and Darryl sharing the apartment is so funny and relatable.
Do you know who came up with it? Well, you know, of course, we had to ask the writer Owen, and here's what he had to say. He said, I think I may have technically pitched it, but really the storyline pitched itself. Two of our people are in a different city. They'd probably be crashing together, and what would that look like?
Daryl being quietly finicky was always a character quirk that I loved, and John leaned into being the bad roommate in such a wonderful way. Well, I agree that this was a genius storyline, and it generated a lot of fan mail. We have a lot of fan catches based on just this opening scene. Here we go. First off, from Caitlin C. and Tyler Texas, who said,
I've always found it strange that Jim is so untidy in this episode, because at the very beginning of the show, during his barbecue, we see that he kept his place and his bedroom very neat and organized. Yeah, but I think my brain could make the leap that he was having a party, so they cleaned up their apartment for the party. Sure.
Sure. And a girl he liked was coming over. Yes. So there might have been extra effort. This is good. And finally we had this fan catch from Noah R. in Freeport, Illinois who said, Okay ladies, this is a weird one, and I apologize in advance. Okay? At 3 minutes, 27 seconds,
when Jim and Daryl are explaining their rooming situation, the camera shows Jim's clothes spread out all over the floor. In this pile, there are a pair of boxers. However, in Pam's wedding video diary from season six super fan episodes, Jim is shown in tighty-whities. This leads me to my question, when did Jim make the switch?
This is not something that needs to be analyzed, but my brain decided to do it anyway, so I thought I would bring it to your attention. Thank you and I'm sorry. Yeah, I love that observation actually, because I remember when we see Jim in the background of Pam's video and we see him in tighty-whities,
I was shocked because I thought Jim was probably a boxer guy. I don's video and we see him in Tidy Whities, I was shocked because I thought Jim was probably a boxer guy. I don't know why, but that's just what I thought. So that is really funny. Like, yeah, when did he make the switch? I don't know, but good catch. You cannot change things. People will notice.
That is what I've learned with our fan mail and with the catches. And also I have to say, we have noticed some things too, Angela. Yeah. I mean here's the beauty of this show. Every time you watch it you discover something new. Whether it's a really great line that a character says. There were a few in this episode that I completely forgot about and made me laugh out loud. I'm gonna point them out when we get to it. Or something in the
background because this show is such a comfort show that you re-watch it so many times. So yeah, I could totally see you catching the fact that Jim switched undies. Well, also in this montage, you see Jim in the background strumming a guitar. Remember earlier in our breakdown, we had a whole debate about whether or not this proved that Jim really plays the guitar. Yeah. Mm-hmm. I mean, he brought it to Philly with him. He did. Back in the warehouse, I love this scene.
Pam is now getting on the lift with a megaphone. She's got her hand on her hip. She is pissed off. Talk about a soapbox. Yeah, exactly. Although I love, I just love the background noise of the lift, like meeeee. I know. It's just so funny.
Yes, she's demanding to know who vandalized her mural and she says, I'm going to stay up here all day if I have to. And then there's a pause and then she's like, meeeee. Maybe I'll come down if I want to. It's my choice. I remember doing that and it like cracked me up doing it. Pam is now going to have a talking head where she says, you know what, unlike Angela, who calls a lawyer whenever someone watches a YouTube video of animals doing it, she doesn't
demand justice often, but someone should be fired over this. She's like, and I'm just kind of on my own here. And then we see a little flirty moment from Brian the Boom guy when he bops her on the head with the boom mic. And she's like, okay, I'm not completely alone. Thank you, Brian. Hmm. Yeah. Yeah.
I feel like Brian is really stepping over the line of that documentary film crew now. Yeah, this was a hot debate. I bet. Because so far, we have only seen or heard from Brian when Pam brings him in. Yeah. But this episode, Brian will be inserting himself. Yes. Mm-hmm. This enraged people, this little boom tap.
It really did. Next up, we are going to, wow, I love this storyline. I can't wait to discuss it. Jim and Daryl are at work, and Jim has walked in drinking coffee out of Daryl's To Go Coffee mug. It's clearly labeled with a piece of tape that says Daryl. Yeah. And Daryl notices. I think we should just skip ahead
because I can't wait to talk about this. Okay, let's do it. So the next beat in the storyline is that Darryl is going to call Jim out for taking his thermos. Yeah. His clearly marked thermos. Yeah. I have an a-hole alert. This begins a standoff in which Jim spitefully pours his coffee out into the trash can. Darrell's like, man, you don't have to do that. But Jim just looks at him with this snarky look and pours it into the trash. And then he goes, do you want me to wash it out as well? And Darrell says, oh, are you going to wash it or just let it soak? Because now Darrell's had it. I know.
Jim then just like hands him the thermos and he walks out. But things would have further escalated with two back-to-back talking heads and they were in the shooting draft. Oh my gosh. Please share. It would have started with a Jim talking head. Jim says, Darrell's being weird. Roommates share stuff. It's not a big deal. I mean, he can use my groceries when I buy some, which I'm gonna. Okay, then it would go to Daryl. Daryl would say, messy is one thing. Now he's screwing with my stuff. He holds up the thermos.
You see that? That's peanut butter. He got peanut butter on my thermos. He shakes his head. You don't do that. You don't go and do that. Well, Jim's position is like, it's no big deal, really. You're going to make a big deal out of this. I'm using your thermos. So I have to ask the question, is it a big deal? If you and I were roommates, and you had a thermos that you liked so much that you took a piece of tape and taped your name to it, I wouldn't use it. I'd be like, clearly, this thermos
means a lot to this person. They have gone out of their way to label it. I wouldn't use it. But isn't the point that, like, Daryl has labeled everything? Daryl doesn't really want to share anything, right? Hmm. Well, then that's your room... Is he too fussy? Maybe, but that's your roommate.
But also, isn't he being forced into some of this fussiness in reaction to Jim's messiness? Like, if he doesn't label his thermos and Jim uses it and doesn't wash it, then he doesn't have a thermos and Jim uses it and doesn't wash it then he doesn't have a thermos. Exactly I support Daryl in this. I support Daryl. Well I think on that note why don't we take a break. Yes and when we come back Pam is hot going to burst into the office and say, conference room meeting.
I had so much fun doing that. I bet. I bet. That's like the best. That's like iconic office moment. Everyone's like, what do you mean, Pam? Why are you calling this conference room meeting? And she's like, listen, David Wallace gave me the clearance
to do this and everyone's like, but then Dwight's like conference room meeting and kind of gets Pam's back. That's all he needed to hear. Yeah, he's such a rule follower. Well, everybody gathers in the conference room and Pam is gonna explain that her mural has been vandalized. They put paint all over her mural.
So now Erin is like, but wait, didn't you want paint all over your mural? And Pam's like, yeah, but not that paint. She goes, so different paints. So it's like very funny, but the dynamic is so classic office. If you're a big fan of the show, I feel like you had to see the parallels
of whenever Michael Scott would hold a meeting and everyone would interject and get him off topic. Yes. It's so fun. I love that Pam also had this moment. Well, Meredith is gonna throw out that she's also upset because someone wrote her number on the men's room wall and they got the number wrong.
It's 6782, not 6783. And then Creed has this great line, and it's one of the ones I was talking about where you watch these episodes so many times and you discover new things. This line made me laugh so hard. He just goes, 6783, also a good time, less mileage. So good.
And then Oscar is so funny. Oscar's like, you know, I just don't think anything can be done. Yeah. And I also love when Phyllis says David Wallace called this meeting. Yeah. And Pam's like, he sure did. Yes. Well, listen, it's clear David Wallace did not call this meeting and nobody cares. No one cares. Everyone leaves except for Dwight and Nellie. They say they will help her.
Yeah, Pam has a talking head where she says, you know what, she wanted this like righteous mob, but instead she ended up with Dwight and Nellie. They do both have mob mentality though. And she's pretty sure that Dwight has a pitchfork in his car. And then Dwight pokes his head in these like, you need my pitchfork?
And he like runs out. We had a fan question about this, Angelet. Antoine S. from Maryland said, I really hope you both read this and discuss. This episode has become hard for me to watch, along with Scott's Tots. Wow. The vandalism of Pam's work is just downright mean.
I know that some of these warehouse guys are newer, but I still can't believe someone would do that. Furthermore, Val really upset me. How, as the boss of the warehouse, does she not step in at all? And then what about certain office workers? Like, how do they not seem to care about Pam's feelings after all of these years of working together? Weddings, baby showers, They are just so indifferent to this situation. You know, Antoine, this is a really good question. I personally liked the iteration that you shared with us, Jenna, where they did write that Val comes out and is like, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry. I think a bunch of the guys got drunk last night
in the warehouse. That's the one that makes the most sense to me. And they did write that. I don't know how it didn't ultimately make it into the shooting draft. But I think there was this feeling that it wasn't as serious as it ended up being. Yeah, I have to say, I think this
might be one of those times when they wrote this stuff about Val and then they took it out. But we all thought it had been addressed because we knew about it. Does that make sense? Yeah, but in taking it out, it does make her seem like she's not trying to help. But there is, you know, there was way more
in the shooting draft where Pam goes to Val's office and they have a whole conversation about it. It was a lot more fleshed out, and none of it made it. I know. So that, to me, for Val as a character, and they have a whole conversation about it. It was a lot more fleshed out and none of it made it. I know. So that to me for Val as a character is a disservice that it didn't make it. The episode was just so big.
Also from the story perspective and now we're getting deep into story here, but Val's help would have been the rational help and for the story to be funny and ultimately end in this scene in the parking lot, Pam needs help from people who aren't good at helping in this moment. Yes, that's true.
She needs to be doing graffiti on a truck. That's right. Val would not have led her that way. No. Right? That's right. So that's the other reason. And then Antoine, one last thing.
You brought up how no one in the office seems to care then, Antoine, one last thing. You brought up how no one in the office seems to care. And I have to agree with you. I think there has been a real pattern over the course of all these seasons that no one really supports Pam's art. No one went to her art show. I know.
Only Michael. So I don't know why everyone's being assholes about that, but yeah. Well, listen, we know why Angela isn't invested in this. being assholes about that, but yeah. Well, listen, we know why Angela isn't invested in this. She's got a lot on her mind. She has a huge party that she is hosting. And now she has to find her extra plus one because the senator gets an extra plus one. She gets to find her stud. That's right. He gets his stud.
Angela is going to approach Dwight and invite him to Philip's birthday party. He said he's not interested. And then Angela's like, but you could pitch your beet salt idea to the state transportation secretary. Okay. Okay. Come on, guys. I have two things about this moment. My first one I titled, hold the phone. Okay. Because you guys remember in the episode, new guys, when Dwight had a talking head where he shared how his summer was,
said he created a new energy drink made of beet runoff. Yes. And then I looked it up and it turns out you can't really drink beet runoff. But then I found that article online about engineers choosing beet runoff, because they were trying to find alternatives to road salt. So they were using this beet runoff salt
and it's less damage to the environment. Jenna. I remembered all of it. The minute I heard the line, I thought this is a real thing. Yes, I was like, our writers knew. Yes. Anyway, I was really tickled by it.
I clearly, I got very excited. I was like, I know about that. What was your second thing? What did you title that? My second thing I didn't title. It's just that this scene was longer in the shooting draft and there was an extra beat between Angela and Dwight where Angela is trying to flirt with Dwight
and it read like this. It really made me laugh, ready? Dwight is at his desk. Angela approaches and flirtily sits on his desk. Dwight, what is it? I have vengeance to exact. Oh, Angela, exciting news. There's room for one more at my son's birthday event
and I want, and she starts poking him, you. Dwight, your fingers are like frozen knitting needles, and I'm not interested.'" And then it would have gone to the next beat where she's like, you could tell the state transportation secretary about your beat salt. But anyway, I just love that moment when he was like, your fingers are like frozen knitting
needles, and I'm not interested. Well, I had a little catch from this scene. Okay. In the moment right before this Pam's having her talking head and Dwight says, do you need a pitchfork? And he runs out the door. The very next scene he's coming from his desk. Yes, because I would have just been sitting on his desk flirting with him. But he just ran out the door to get his pitchfork.
I know it doesn't add up. It doesn't add up. Well I'll tell you Dwight isn't going to the car and he isn't going to the party where he's going, it's to the warehouse. He has a plan. He is going to have every warehouse employee draw a butt and sign it. And then he's going to compare those drawings to the butts on the mural. But the folks in the warehouse are on to him.
They're like, you're just trying to see if we draw butts like the butt on the mural. But the folks in the warehouse are on to him. They're like, you're just trying to see if we draw butts like the butt on the mural. And then Nellie's like, how about drawing big Ws? Yes. And Dwight says, or breasts without nipples. All right. This is one we're going to get introduced to Frank, played by Brad William Hanke, who is famous for his roles on October Road, Justified, Orange is the New Black, and of course, Lost. Yeah.
Which was noticed by Rochelle M. from Dunnville, Ontario, Canada, who said, you know, throughout the series, Dwight makes a lot of Lost references. Wouldn't Dwight have recognized him from the show? I wish he had. I wish he had. I wish he had said, you look a lot like that guy on Lost.
I know. And I thought this was interesting. According to Brad's IMDB trivia, prior to beginning his acting career, he played defensive line at the University of Arizona and was drafted by the New York Giants in 1989. Wow. After being cut from the Giants, he played for the Denver Broncos in Super Bowl 24.
我知道。我觉得这很有趣。根据布拉德的IMDB趣闻，在他开始演艺生涯之前，他曾在亚利桑那大学担任防守锋线，并在1989年被纽约巨人队选中。哇。在被巨人队裁掉后，他在第24届超级碗中代表丹佛野马队出场。
Then he retired from professional football in 1994 following numerous injuries and became an actor. Wow. That's so cool. This drawing of the W or the butts or the boobs, it's not working. So they switch gears. Dwight's like, okay, Nate is who's going to crack. And I know just how to get him to crack. I'm gonna tell him that his mother died, it usually works. Poor Nate. I know.
然后在1994年由于多次受伤，他退出了职业橄榄球界并成为了一名演员。哇。太酷了。这幅画，那个W、屁股还是胸部，行不通。所以他们改变了策略。德怀特心想，好吧，内特才是那个会崩溃的人。我知道怎么让他崩溃。我要告诉他他妈妈死了，这招通常管用。可怜的内特。我知道。
Poor Nate. He's like, oh no, not again. And then Dwight's like, guess what? She's pulling through. She's gonna be fine. He's like, what? Yeah, they get Nate in Val's office and they are gonna get him to say, who did it?
可怜的内特。他一副“噢不，不会吧”的表情。然后德怀特说，你猜怎么着？她挺过来了。她会没事的。他说，什么？对，他们把内特弄到了瓦尔的办公室，他们要让他说出，是谁干的？
Who vandalized the mural? It didn't take much. Angela, there was an improv by Mark Brooks, who plays Nate, that was so funny and unexpected. It is my favorite blooper. I can't believe we didn't get it in the episode. Clearly we just all broke, and I don't know why we didn't redo it in the episode. Clearly we just all broke and I don't
是谁破坏了壁画？没花多大力气。安吉拉，饰演内特的马克·布鲁克斯有一个即兴表演，太搞笑了，而且完全出乎意料。这是我最喜欢的NG镜头。真不敢相信我们没有把它剪进正片里。显然我们当时都笑场了，我不知道为什么我们没有在正片里重拍一次。显然我们当时都笑场了，我不知道为什么我们没
know why we didn't redo it and make this the new thing. I have to play it for you. It was amazing. Frank did it? I don't know his last name. It's Frank. Frank did it? Did it. Sure. Frank did it. Did it. It is so good. I have seen that blooper before, but it is so good. Sure, Frank did it, did it. Exactly. That is so good.
有重拍一次，把这变成新的桥段。我得放给你听听。太棒了。是弗兰克干的？我不知道他姓什么。就是弗兰克。是弗兰克干的？干的。没错。是弗兰克干的？干的。太棒了。我以前看过那个NG镜头，但真的是太棒了。没错，是弗兰克干的，干的。没错。太棒了。
He's so funny. We laughed so hard in that office doing that interrogation. I remember the first time that I like slammed my hand down and I said, who did it? We all laughed. I don't know why. Like everything about it was just so... Over the top. Yes.
他太搞笑了。我们在那个办公室里做审讯时笑得前仰后合。我记得第一次我用力拍下桌子说，是谁干的？我们都笑了。我不知道为什么。就像关于它的一切都那么……夸张。是的。
It was so funny. We just laughed so hard in that room. Oh my gosh. Frank did it, did it. I know. It's too good. Well, now we're gonna go to the Lipton's party. Yes, Kevin has come.
太搞笑了。我们在那个房间里笑得太厉害了。天哪。是弗兰克干的，干的。我知道。太精彩了。好吧，现在我们要去利普顿的派对。是的，凯文来了。
Yes, oh, we should say that. When Dwight wasn't able to go, Kevin was like, I'll go. And Angela's like, no. And he goes, you're gonna leave me here alone with all the money. And Angela's like, no. And he goes, you're going to leave me here alone with all the money? And she's like, fine. Kevin is there for the appetizers. He's loving the puff pastries.
是的，哦，我们应该说一下。当德怀特去不了时，凯文说，我去。安吉拉说，不行。然后他说，你要把我一个人留在这里面对所有的钱吗？安吉拉说，不行。然后他说，你要把我一个人留在这里面对所有的钱吗？她说，好吧。凯文是为了开胃菜而去的。他超爱那些酥皮点心。
He and Oscar during the scene are standing below a ginormous portrait of Angela looking very stern. I would love for you guys to know that the set deck department gave me that ginormous painting of myself. It's like a print that looks like a painting. Yes. In the frame, I have it. For years, it hung in my hallway.
他和奥斯卡在这个场景中站在一幅巨大的安吉拉肖像下方，画像上的安吉拉看起来非常严肃。我很想让你们知道，道具组送了我那幅巨大的我自己的画。它就像一张看起来像油画的印刷品。是的。在画框里，我有它。多年来，它一直挂在我的走廊里。
And then I thought, you know what? That's just kind of weird, like when people come over. And I took it down. I still have it, though. Maybe I'll put it back up. Matt Sohn was also DP, as Lee mentioned. And he took a down. I still have it though. Maybe I'll put it back up. Matt Sohn was also DP as Lee mentioned, and he took a picture of me looking stern in front of a painting of myself looking stern.
然后我想，你知道吗？这感觉有点怪，尤其是当别人来家里的时候。于是我把它取了下来。不过我依然留着它。也许我会把它重新挂起来。正如李所提到的，马特·索恩也是摄影指导。他拍下了一张我站在一幅我自己看起来很严肃的画前、表情也很严肃的照片。
And I have that picture, it's so great. That's what you need to blow up and put in your house. That's very funny. You know, that's a funny quirk that I have seen sometimes when I go to entertainers' homes. There are kind of like the people that decorate their homes with giant portraits of themselves. It's such a thing, right?
我有那张照片，太棒了。这就是你需要放大并挂在家里的东西。太搞笑了。你知道，我在去一些演艺人员的家里时，有时会看到一种有趣的怪癖。就是那种用自己巨幅肖像来装饰家里的现象。这真是一种潮流，对吧？
Do you know what I'm talking about? Yeah. Yeah. Some people have sort of like an ode to myself. I would say in my home office, I have like a The Office memorabilia nook. Yes. You know? A lot of times I will get gifted giant portraits of myself.
你知道我在说什么吗？是的。是的。有些人会搞一些类似于对自己的赞歌的东西。我想说，在我的家庭办公室里，我有一个《办公室》的纪念品角落。是的。你知道吗？很多时候我会收到别人送给我的巨幅个人肖像。
From a project. From a project, kind of like what you're talking about. Yeah. But it'll even be like from a magazine shoot. Yes. Then as like a thank you, they'll send to my house. Yes. Like a giant.
来自某个项目。来自某个项目，有点像你刚才说的。是的。但甚至会是来自某本杂志的拍摄。是的。然后作为一种感谢，他们会寄到我家。是的。比如一个巨大的。
Yes. Picture of my face or of me doing the shoot. And I always think to myself, what am I doing with this item? I'm too shy to decorate my home with just portraits of me. I know, it's weird. It's really weird. I will say I have one picture of myself like that, that's up, it is in my upstairs hallway.
是的。印着我脸的或者我正在拍摄的照片。我总是对自己说，我拿这个东西有什么用？我太害羞了，不会用一屋子自己的肖像来装饰家。我知道，这很奇怪。真的很怪。不过得承认，我确实有一张那样自己的照片挂着，它在楼上的走廊里。
So guests don't normally see it. But I did a photo shoot for an animal charity. And I am dressed as Marie Antoinette. And I'm holding little kittens. I love that picture. And the photographer, it was just this amazing photo. And after the shoot, they sent it to me in a giant frame. And it is above our piano in our upstairs little alcove.
所以客人们通常看不到。但我曾经为一个动物慈善机构拍过一组照片。我打扮成玛丽·安托瓦内特的样子。怀里抱着小猫咪。我很喜欢那张照片。摄影师拍出来的效果简直太惊艳了。拍摄结束后，他们把它装在一个巨大的画框里寄给了我。现在它挂在我们楼上小休息区钢琴的上方。
I love it. I have one. That's pretty cool. That is kind of cool. I love it. I have one. So that's pretty cool. That is kind of cool. I, one last thing, I did this project, which I can't talk about yet, and Zach Woods directed it. I can't say that. Okay.
我太喜欢了。我有一个。挺酷的。确实挺酷的。我太喜欢了。我有一个。所以挺酷的。确实挺酷的。我，还有最后一件事，我参与了这个项目，我还不能谈论它，扎克·伍兹是导演。我不能说这个。好吧。
Zach Woods, amazing. Yep. He directed it, and he gave me a gift, and it's a photo of myself doing this thing. At some point, I'm going to share it. But I hung it in my podcast closet. Okay, very good. Not above your fireplace. Not above my fireplace or in my entryway.
扎克·伍兹，太棒了。没错。他执导了这个项目，并送了我一份礼物，是一张我正在做这件事的照片。在某个时候，我会分享它。但我把它挂在了我的播客储藏室里。好吧，非常好。不是挂在壁炉上方。不是挂在我的壁炉上方，也不是在门厅里。
I do love the line that Oscar has here though. He sort of looks up at the painting and he made Brian break more than once because they don't realize they're standing under the portrait and Oscar looks up at it and there was one take where Oscar went, huh, like that. And it made Brian crack up. And he has this line where he says, how can anyone who weighs less than a guinea hen be
不过我确实很喜欢奥斯卡在这里的台词。他抬头看着那幅画，他让布莱恩不止一次笑场，因为他们没有意识到自己正站在画像下方，奥斯卡抬头看了看，其中有一个镜头里奥斯卡“哼”了一声，像这样。这让布莱恩笑崩了。他有一句台词是，怎么会有人体重比母珍珠鸡还轻，
so terrifying? Well, now the senator and Angela come in. Angela, you're holding the baby, and we now know that this is the only take of this moment that was achieved. Yes, we got this, I guess, in one take. I didn't remember that, but oh my gosh. Here is how it read in the shooting draft. I wanted to set the scene for you all. The Senator and Angela enter, looking sharp. Angela is holding Philip, who's dressed in a baptismal robe. Angela hands
却如此吓人？好吧，现在议员和安吉拉进来了。安吉拉，你抱着孩子，我们现在知道这是这一幕唯一一次就拍成功的镜头。是的，我们大概一条就过了。我不记得了，但天哪。剧本里原本是这样写的。我想为你们大家还原一下场景。议员和安吉拉精神抖擞地走了进来。安吉拉抱着菲利普，菲利普穿着洗礼长袍。安吉拉把他
him to an Irish nurse who immediately carries him back out of the room. Senator Lipton would have said, Thanks for coming everyone. Philip didn't realize he was so popular. Everyone laughs. Angela's laugh is especially hard. I had a lot of fun doing that because I went, ha ha ha ha. I remember. Robert, you're terrible. And then Angela notices a couple. Simon and Maxine, who let you guys in here? More laughter.
递给了一位爱尔兰护士，护士立刻把他抱出了房间。利普顿议员本该说，谢谢大家光临。菲利普没意识到自己这么受欢迎。大家都笑了。安吉拉的笑声格外大。我演那个特别开心，因为我发出“哈哈哈哈哈”的笑声。我记得。罗伯特，你太差劲了。然后安吉拉注意到了两个人。西蒙和马克辛，谁让你们进这儿来的？更多笑声。
Kevin, wow, turns out Angela and her husband are really funny. He finishes his hors d'oeuvre. Oscar looks sad. I loved it whenever my character got to take great pride in being the senator's wife. It's some of my favorite storyline beats. She loves being highfalutin. This side of Angela.
凯文，哇，原来安吉拉和她丈夫这么搞笑。他吃完了开胃小菜。奥斯卡看起来很伤心。每当我能为我的角色作为议员夫人的巨大骄傲感而感到高兴时，我都爱极了。这是我最喜欢的剧情走向之一。她就喜欢装腔作势。安吉拉这一面。
We are now back in the conference room. Nellie and Pam and Toby are all questioning Frank. Pam wants an apology. She wants him to fess up. That's right. So I guess, Pam, to get his apology, her strategy is to first apologize to Frank if she did anything to upset him. She's trying to be very diplomatic,
我们现在回到了会议室。内莉、帕姆和托比都在盘问弗兰克。帕姆想要一个道歉。她想让他招认。没错。所以我想，帕姆为了得到他的道歉，她的策略是首先如果自己有什么做的不对的地方惹到了弗兰克，先向他道歉。她试图表现得非常外交辞令，
but also it's, I think, it's a little bit patronizing, right? Well, yeah. Frank isn't having any of it. He says, you know what? I'll apologize for not liking your doodles. And he says that butts are funny. And he also says, and you know what,
但同时，我觉得，这也有点居高临下，对吧？好吧，是的。弗兰克根本不吃这一套。他说，你知道吗？我为我不喜欢你的涂鸦道歉。他还说屁股很好笑。他还说，而且你知道吗，
you can't fire me. And he leaves. Toby was useless, basically, in this scene. Now, you mentioned earlier that there was a storyline that got deleted, and I'm very curious about it, Angela, because I'm a little bit thinking, how did Toby get involved in this? Okay, well, he's the head of HR. Sure. Right?
你开除不了我。然后他走了。在这场戏里，托比基本上没什么用。现在，你刚才提到有一个被删掉的剧情线，我对此很好奇，安吉拉，因为我在想，托比是怎么卷入进来的？好吧，他是人事部主管。没错。对吧？
And there was a deleted Toby runner that I loved. It's in deleted scenes. And basically Toby is alone with Frank in the conference room. Pam and Nellie have left. They have stepped outside, but they are watching through the glass window. Yes.
有一个我很喜欢的被删掉的托比支线。它在删除片段里。基本上就是托比和弗兰克单独在会议室里。帕姆和内莉已经离开了。她们走到了外面，但她们正透过玻璃窗看着。是的。
And Toby is wanting to impress Nellie. So he's kind of under his breath as he's questioning Frank. He's like, I'm gonna make big hand movements. And he kind of tells Frank, he's trying to impress this gal outside the window. Here, you have to hear it. So this is technically an HR issue. I am supposed to chill you out. Definitely not going to do that. But I am kind of jockeying that girl over there. So I'd love it if we could pretend I'm being tough.
托比想要给内莉留下好印象。所以在审问弗兰克时，他压低了声音自言自语。他说，我要做夸张的手势。他有点告诉弗兰克，他正试图给窗外那个女孩留下好印象。听着，你必须听听这个。所以这在技术上是一个人事问题。我本该让你冷静下来的。我绝对不会那样做。但我有点在追求那边那个女孩。所以如果我们可以假装我很严厉，我会很感激的。
You're pathetic. You're pathetic. All right, all right. But there's behavior of yours that I am saying things to address. Toby is really going at him. He's tearing strips off him. It's great. You know? I have this look on my face, okay?
你真可悲。你真可悲。好吧，好吧。但你的某些行为是我必须要出面处理的。托比真的在对付他。他把对方批得体无完肤。太棒了。你知道吗？我脸上带着这种表情，好吗？
It's very serious. Being tough. And I really, really appreciate what you're doing here. I have this look on my face, okay? It's very serious, being tough, and I really, really appreciate what you're doing here. You are the largest vagina I've ever seen in my life. Okay, I'll let that one go in the warning. I'll put my glasses back on now. And I think it's working, so I only have one. You can go
非常严肃。表现得很强硬。我真的很感激你在这里做的事。我脸上带着这种表情，好吗？非常严肃，表现得很强硬，我真的很感激你在这里做的事。你是我这辈子见过最大的阴道。好吧，这个警告我就不计较了。我现在把眼镜戴回去。我觉得这挺管用的，所以我只有一个。你随时可以
anytime you want. It'd be to you to get out of here, then do that. That's what you want. So he's doing all this business. Like he's like, and I am looking at you with this face and I'm looking sternly at you. I'm gonna take my glasses off. I'm gonna put them back on. Like he's doing, his motions don't match his voice
走，如果你想离开的话，那就走。这正是你想要的。所以他在做各种动作。就像他这样，我正用这个表情看着你，我正严厉地看着你。我要摘下眼镜。我要把它戴回去。就像他在做的那样，他的动作和声音根本不搭，
because he's like kind of being, and Nellie and Pam can only see Frank's back and then they just see Toby's face and his hand gestures and he's selling it, so he's really happy about it. Now does this reignite any interest in Nellie? Nellie goes, who knew? Oh. Yeah.
因为他有点在装腔作势，而内莉和帕姆只能看到弗兰克的背影，然后她们只能看到托比的表情和手势，而且他演得很投入，所以他对此感到非常高兴。这会重新点燃内莉对他的兴趣吗？内莉说，谁能想到呢？哦。
And Toby's like, I think it's working. OK. So I'm not sure if this scene came before the three of them were in the room or after because Frank storms out in both. Right. But or maybe it was an alt. Sure.
然后托比说，我觉得这管用。好吧。所以我不确定这场戏是在他们三人都在房间之前还是之后，因为弗兰克在这两种情况下都气冲冲地走了出去。对的。但也许那是个备选镜头。没错。
I tried to find the candy bag alts. I didn't have them for this episode. But it was really funny. But it does set why Toby's there. He says, I'm the head of HR. Okay. Okay. But it's really funny.
我试着找糖果袋的备选镜头。这一集我没有。但真的很好笑。不过它确实交代了为什么托比会出现在那儿。他说，我是人事主管。好吧。好吧。但真的很好笑。
Like, Paul is very funny in this scene. Well, since that didn't work, Pam is going to have to turn to Dwight. Yeah. She wants to go scorched earth on that guy's face. Dwight is in. He loves this side of Pam. He says, you know, typically he sees Pam as a comforting, unarousing presence in the office, like a well-watered fern, but he's really liking the side of her.
保罗在这场戏里非常搞笑。既然这招不管用，帕姆就只能求助于德怀特了。是的。她想对那家伙的脸实施焦土政策。德怀特加入。他很喜欢帕姆的这一面。他说，通常情况下，他觉得帕姆办公室里一个令人宽慰的、毫无情欲的存在，就像一盆浇了水的蕨类植物，但他真的很喜欢她的这一面。
It's making him notice her and she has a good butt. Yes. Suddenly. All right. Well, I guess they need an infiltrator is what Dwight says. They need a mole. They're going to send in Clark. Clark.
这让他注意到了她，而且她身材很好。是的。突然间。好吧，我想他们需要一个卧底，德怀特是这么说的。他们需要一个内应。他们要派克拉克去。克拉克。
I feel like Clark is the new Meredith. He's just having to do a lot of things. Physical comedy. Yes. It's true. Should we talk this out? Should we stay here? Yeah, let's do it.
我觉得克拉克就是新梅丽娜。他不得不做很多事情。肢体喜剧。是的。确实如此。我们要把这个讨论完吗？我们要留在这里吗？对，我们开始吧。
All right. Dwight and Pam are going to very loudly banish Clark to the warehouse. Yeah, they march him over to that big warehouse loading dock door. He's in a, it looks like a jumpsuit, like a warehouse jumpsuit. Yep. And they're like, you have to work down here now. And oh my gosh, Clark is so funny. He's like, you realize this is not going to work, right?
好吧。德怀特和帕姆要大声把克拉克流放到仓库去。对，他们把他押到那个大仓库的货运月台门前。他穿着一套，看起来像工装裤，就像仓库工人的工装裤。是的。他们说，你现在必须在楼下工作了。天哪，克拉克太搞笑了。他说，你们意识到这行不通的，对吧？
He's like, Pam, you're a reasonable person. Yeah. And she's like, get in there and remember your script. So now we're gonna cut to Dwight and Pam, and they're up on that landing at the top of the stairwell, and this is where they're spying through the giant binoculars at everyone in the warehouse. You know, that door went to nowhere. Right. We've discussed it was just a tiny little cubby where you could hide. This scene was one of my favorite scenes to shoot.
他说，帕姆，你是个讲道理的人。是的。然后她说，进去，记住你的台词。现在我们要切到德怀特和帕姆，他们站在楼梯顶部的平台上，这就是他们用巨型望远镜窥视仓库里每个人的地方。你知道，那扇门通往一个死胡同。对的。我们讨论过，那只是一个可以藏身的小隔间。这场戏是我最喜欢的拍摄场景之一。
I really do love a stakeout. I really do. Me too. It was a lot of fun. Yeah, I love a stakeout. I loved when Oscar and Angela would spy on the senator. So fun. Why are they so fun?
我真的很喜欢搞盯梢。真的。我也是。太好玩了。对，我很喜欢盯梢。我喜欢奥斯卡和安吉拉监视议员的时候。太好玩了。为什么它们这么有趣？
I don't know. Are they fun in real life? I've never been on one in real life other than like me walking in my neighborhood snooping on people. We need to stake something out. I think it's boring, right? Because a lot of staking out is just the eating of snacks.
我不知道。现实生活中有趣吗？除了在我的社区散步时窥探别人之外，我在现实生活中从来没做过这事。我们需要去监视点什么。我觉得挺无聊的，对吧？因为大部分盯梢时间都只是在吃零食。
But then that takes me back to it being fun again. Anyway, the end of this scene, the camera's going to pan down, and we're going to see that Clark was, I guess, immediately duct taped to a chair, and the words, spy, you'll pay for this, are written across his chest in black marker. Well, you might be wondering why spy is scratched out, and then you'll pay for this is written under it.
但这就又让我觉得它重新变得有趣了。总之，这场戏的最后，镜头会向下摇，我们会看到克拉克，我猜，立刻被用胶带绑在了椅子上，他的胸口用黑色记号笔写着“间谍，你会为此付出代价的”。好吧，你可能在想为什么“间谍”被划掉了，然后下面写着“你会为此付出代价的”。
OK. If you are wondering folks out there, I have the answer. Okay. Here is the backstory. In the shooting draft, and it's also in deleted scenes for folks with the DVD, you know we are on disc three of season nine everybody. Yeah. Yeah. Disc three. So there's a scene where Pam and Dwight are in the bullpen. Okay. The main office area and they're waiting for Clark to report back. And then off in the distance by the elevators, we hear Phil is screaming, Dwight, Dwight! So Pam and Dwight go running to the elevators and the doors are opened and sitting shirtless, duct taped to a chair is Clark.
好吧。如果各位观众朋友们在纳闷，我有答案。好吧。背景故事是这样的。在拍摄剧本中，对于拥有DVD的观众，这也是删除场景的内容，你知道我们在看第九季的第三张光盘，各位。对的。对的。第三张光盘。所以有一个场景，帕姆和德怀特在办公区。好吧。主要办公区，他们在等克拉克回来。然后远处的电梯旁，我们听到菲尔在尖叫，德怀特，德怀特！于是帕姆和德怀特向电梯跑去，门开了，光着膀子、用胶带绑在椅子上的是克拉克。
And the word spy is written across his chest. Dwight is furious. He says, oh, they're gonna pay for this. Then he takes the Sharpie and he draws a line through the word spy, crossing it out, and writes under it, you'll pay for this on Clark's chest. And he's like, we're gonna send you back down there with this message.
他的胸口写着“间谍”这个词。德怀特怒不可遏。他说，哦，他们会为此付出代价的。然后他拿起马克笔在“间谍”这个词上划了一道线，将其划掉，并在克拉克的胸口写下“你会为此付出代价的”。他说，我们要带着这个信息把你送回楼下去。
And Clark's like, come on, please, guys. I'm remembering all this now that you're saying it. Clark's like, Pam, you know that this is ridiculous, right, Pam? And the doors are shutting on him. And so that is how they send Clark back to the warehouse. I just loved how in this instance of Dwight and Pam teaming up, just how immediately infected by his bad ideas that she was because she was out for vengeance. It was very funny to me. Yeah. It sort of altered all her normal reasoning.
克拉克说，拜托，求你们了，伙计们。经你这么一说，我想起这些了。克拉克说，帕姆，你知道这太荒谬了，对吧，帕姆？门在他面前关上了。这就是他们把克拉克送回仓库的方式。我只是觉得，在德怀特和帕姆组队这件事上，她对他的坏主意是多么的立马就中毒效仿，因为她是来复仇的。我觉得这非常搞笑。是的。这改变了她所有的正常理智。
Yes. Well, let's go back to the senator's house. Oscar is holding court with some donors. Yeah. And you know, Lee talked about how there was a lot of extra Angela, Oscar, Kevin moments. Yes. While Oscar's holding court, Kevin and Angela are watching. The scene did not make it in. It's in deleted scenes. There's no dialogue, so I'm going to describe it to you, but it's so funny. Kevin is standing, eating what looks to be like a pizza pocket, some kind of pizza pocket, meatball looking thing.
是的。好吧，让我们回到议员家。奥斯卡正在与一些赞助商交谈。是的。你知道，李谈到了有很多关于安吉拉、奥斯卡、凯文的额外桥段。是的。当奥斯卡在与人交谈时，凯文和安吉拉在看着。这个场景没有剪进正片里。它在删除片段中。没有对话，所以我来向你描述一下，但它太搞笑了。凯文站在那里，吃着看起来像是披萨口袋的东西，某种披萨口袋，看起来像肉丸的东西。
And Angela is sitting on the ottoman and she's just watching Oscar and she's just so ticked off, just watching him and like, ugh, and while Kevin is eating the pizza pocket, it kind of busts open with the marinara sauce and it dribbles onto the ottoman Angela's sitting on, right next to her. And it was like a whole thing we had to time out.
而安吉拉坐在脚凳上，只是看着奥斯卡，她气炸了，就这么看着他，一脸嫌弃。就在凯文吃着披萨包时，它突然裂开，番茄酱流了出来，滴在了安吉拉坐着的脚凳上，就在她旁边。这是我们不得不掐表算好的一整套动作。
Because it can't hit me, but it has to get right next to me onto the furniture. And then Kevin is trying to clean it, but Angela is never aware because she's just so ticked off and watching Oscar. This is just one of these little moments I loved. I'm going to put it in stories. I think this is probably a moment that Leigh loved because it was one of those little just slice of life moments. Exactly. Okay, Angela, since you mentioned another hors d'oeuvre, I did do something.
因为酱汁不能溅到我身上，但必须落在我身旁 家具上的那个位子。然后凯文试图清理，但安吉拉完全没察觉，因为她气炸了，正盯着奥斯卡。这正是这类让我喜爱的小细节之一。我要把它发到快拍里。我想这可能也是利很喜欢的时刻，因为它就是那种充满生活气息的小片段。没错。好吧，安吉拉，既然你提到了另一种开胃菜，我确实做了一件事。
I had skipped it from earlier, but I'm going to bring it up here, but I'm going to give you a choice. Okay. I have a tangent choice. Oh, okay. Would you like a mini deep dive on the best past appetizers at a party? Or would you like an update on telephone landlines? Oh, this is so tough.
我刚才跳过了，但现在我要把它提出来，不过我要让你做个选择。好吧。我有一个题外话选项。哦，好吧。你想要一个关于派对上最佳往期开胃菜的迷你深度解析？还是想要一个关于固定电话最新情况的更新？哦，这太难了。
I mean, I love appetizers. I know. I know. I love like anything bite size. You know, I do too. I love a mini dessert. I love a mini food. Close behind is any mini food at all
我是说，我超爱开胃菜。我知道。我知道。我喜欢任何一口大小的东西。我也是。我喜欢迷你甜点。我喜欢迷你食物。紧随其后的是任何你可以一口吃掉的
that you can pop in your mouth. Oh man. I could eat a whole dinner of appetizers. I wanna know the best past appetizers, but then will you save landline for next week? I will. All right, here it is. According to DailyMeal.com,
迷你食物。天啊。我可以拿开胃菜当一整顿饭吃。我想知道最佳往期开胃菜是什么，但那你下周还会保留固定电话的话题吗？我会的。好吧，公布了。根据DailyMeal.com的报道，
here are the best past appetizers ranked. Number 13, sliders. 13? I know. There's 13 and number 13 is sliders. Okay. Number 12 is crab cakes. Okay. 11 skewers. 10 blinis topped with caviar. Bellinis? Like the drink? No, bellinis. Oh, the cracker. The little pancake thing. Wafer thing, yeah. It's not a wafer, it's a pancake.
以下是最佳开胃菜的排名。第13名，小汉堡。第13名？我知道。总共有13个，而第13名就是小汉堡。好吧。第12名是蟹饼。好吧。第11名，烤串。第10名，配有鱼子酱的意式小圆饼。意式小圆饼？就像那种饮料？不，是意式小圆饼。哦，就是那种饼干。那种小煎饼之类的。华夫饼之类的，对。它不是华夫饼，它是煎饼。
I know. It's soft. Yeah. Do you like that I went to bellinis? That's very different. Okay, go ahead. Well, listen, a bellini topped with caviar, I don't know. That's a drink special. Nine. Pigs's a drink special. Nine pigs in a blanket. I love pigs in a blanket. I'm a nine.
我知道。它是软的。没错。你喜欢我提到意式小圆饼吗？那很与众不同。好吧，你继续。听着，配鱼子酱的意式小圆饼，我不知道。那是特饮吧。第9名。猪是特饮。第9名，小猪盖被。我超爱小猪盖被。我给第9名。
We'll you hear some of their top ones. And I'm sorry, but sliders and pigs in a blanket need to move up the list. Yeah. Number eight, bruschetta. Seven, shrimp cocktail. I love shrimp cocktail. As a past appetizer. Not really.
接下来你们会听到一些名列前茅的。不好意思，但小汉堡和小猪盖被需要在这份榜单上名次靠前一点。对。第8名，意式烤面包。第7名，鲜虾鸡尾酒。我超爱鲜虾鸡尾酒。作为一种往期开胃菜？其实并不算。
They were showing a picture of it in like a little shot glass and there'd be like a little cocktail sauce at the bottom and then the shrimp, a single shrimp. So it was like a little single, I'm sorry, I'm going to say something right now. It's not a past appetizer if you're left with any kind of thing. Container. Yes. And I'm going to include mini spoon or mini fork in that. Yours is like a napkin.
他们展示了一张照片，它放在一个小烈酒杯里，底部有一点鸡尾酒酱，然后是一只虾，单单一只虾。所以它就像是一个小单品，不好意思，我得说一句话。如果你最后还得处理某种东西，那它就不能算往期开胃菜。容器。没错。而且我把迷你勺子或迷你叉子也归为这一类。你拿到的是一张纸巾。
I have a napkin. What can I eat out of a napkin? That's right. And then I'm going to take your thing, I'm going to pop it in my mouth, I'm going to use the napkin. Okay. I don't want to have a toothpick. I don't want to have a mini spoon.
我有一张纸巾。我能用纸巾吃什么？没错。然后我会拿走你的东西，把它塞进嘴里，接着我就会用纸巾。好吧。我可不想拿一根牙签。我也不想拿一把迷你勺子。
I don't want to have a mini fork. And I definitely don't want to have a tiny shot glass that now I'm saddled with. Okay. Okay. Strong feelings there from me. Strong feelings, yeah. Okay, next stuffed mushrooms. Number five, oysters. What?
我更不想拿一把迷你叉子。我绝对不想拿一个小烈酒杯，然后现在还得由我来善后。好吧。好吧。我对此有强烈的感受。强烈的感受，是的。好吧，接下来是酿口蘑。第5名，生蚝。什么？
That's not a past appetizer. As an appetizer, I don't know. Then you're stuck with the shell. I know, that's what I'm saying. Yeah. It's, I, it enrages me. I can't have it. Okay, number four, I don't know how to say it.
那可不是往期开胃菜。作为开胃菜，我不知道。那你就得带着生蚝壳。我知道，这就是我要说的。对。这，我，这气死我了。我不能接受。好吧，第4名，我不知道怎么发音。
Oh. I had to look it up. Oh, sound it out. Arancini. How dare you? Is that it? No, I don't know. It's a stuffed rice ball.
哦。我得查一下。哦，拼出来。阿尔兰奇尼（炸饭团）。你怎么敢？是这个吗？不，我不知道。它是一个夹心饭团。
Oh. They explain that this is higher on our list because the dish can appeal to a wide variety of palates, from carnivores to vegetarians. Each rice nugget is a bite-sized carb bomb and can be stuffed with cheese. Many cheeses, Angela. Mozzarella, salty Parmesan, soft ricotta.
哦。他们解释说，这个在我们的榜单上排名靠前，是因为这道菜可以迎合各种不同的口味，从食肉动物到素食主义者。每一个饭团都是一口大小的碳水炸弹，而且里面可以塞满奶酪。各种奶酪，安吉拉。马苏里拉奶酪，咸香的帕玛森奶酪，软绵绵的里科塔奶酪。
Or you could have some meat in there, or pork sausage. You know what happens to me with one of these? What? I get real excited because I'm usually really hungry by the time they're passed around. And I pop one in my mouth and the inside is so hot. Oh yeah. And then you're like,
或者你可以在里面加点肉，或者猪肉香肠。你知道我吃这个会怎么样吗？什么？我会变得超级兴奋，因为当它们端上来时，我通常已经饿得前胸贴后肚了。然后我一口吞下一个，结果里面超级烫。哦对。然后你就会觉得，
ha ha ha. Yep. Yeah. Yeah. And it's a hot sticky goo. Yeah. Yeah. All right.
哈，哈，哈。没错。对。对。而且黏糊糊烫得要命。对。对。好吧。
The top three, I'm sorry, a no. Number three, stuffed endives. No. I don't want your piece of lettuce with stuff in it. They need to rethink this list. Number two, canapes, a number one, flatbread. Flatbread? Flatbread.
前三名，不好意思，绝对不要。第3名，酿菊苣。不要。我才不要吃你那些塞满东西的生菜叶。他们得重新考虑这份榜单了。第2名，法式小点心，第1名，扁面包。扁面包？扁面包。
Is that like a pizza? I guess a piece of flatbread. A piece of flatbread. But not a mini pizza, like a slice of flatbread. Daily meal, I want you to redo this list. I'm also gonna go a little basic and say, those tiny little pizza things are good. Yeah, or how about a mac and cheese ball?
那就像披萨吗？我猜就是一块扁面包。一块扁面包。但不是迷你披萨，就像是一片扁面包。DailyMeal网站，我命令你们重新做一份榜单。我还要说得基础一点，那些迷你小披萨饼挺好吃的。对，或者来个通心粉奶酪球怎么样？
Yeah, I love a skewer. Put it on a stick. I don't mind having to ditch the stick. I don't want your stick. I want the stick. I want some chicken on it or shrimp on it. Give me your skewer. I'll take yours. You don't have to worry about the stick. I don't want your stick. I want the stick. I want some chicken on it or shrimp on it. Give me your skewer. I'll take yours. You don't have to worry about stick. Well, if you take my stick, I'll hold your skewer. And also finally, I'm with Kevin anything in a puff pastry. Bingo. Literally anything. Bingo, bingo. Whatever you want to put in it. Put it in a pastry, I'm going to eat it.
对，我超爱烤串。把它串在棍子上。我不介意把棍子扔掉。我才不要你的棍子。我就要棍子。上面得有鸡肉或者虾。把你的烤串给我。我拿你的。你不用担心棍子。我才不要你的棍子。我就要棍子。上面得有鸡肉或者虾。把你的烤串给我。我拿你的。你不用担心棍子。好吧，如果你拿我的棍子，我就帮你拿烤串。最后，我完全支持凯文的看法，任何酥皮点心都可以。太棒了。字面意义上的任何东西。太棒了，太棒了。不管你想往里面塞什么。塞进酥皮里，我就会吃掉它。
All right, there you have it. I will save my landline update for another time, but I will give you this teaser. Front page of the New York Times Sunday edition. Your landline was on the front page of the, what? What? What? Why would you hold onto that? That's such big news.
好了，就是这样。我的固定电话最新进展要留到以后再说，但我先给你们留个悬念。纽约时报周日版的头版。你的固定电话竟然上了那个什么头版？什么？什么？这么大的事你为什么现在才说？
Why did you let me pick puff pastries? That was huge. Not my landline. Landlines in general. Yes. I thought you were giving us an update on your landline. Well, it's a little bit an update on my landline. I'll save it.
你为什么让我选酥皮点心？这可是个大新闻。不是我的固定电话。是固定电话整体。对。我还以为你要给我们更新你家固定电话的情况呢。好吧，这确实有点算是我家固定电话的进展。我先留着不讲。
All right. But there's your teaser. Okay. That was a tangent. Yeah. Is anyone with us? Are people starving now? I'm hungry. God, I want to eat all of it.
好吧。不过这就是悬念。好吧。那真是个题外话。对。有人还在听吗？大家现在都饿了吗？我饿了。天哪，我想把它们全吃光。
Where even are we? Okay, here, I got it. I got it. We are going to find out that the only reason that Robert invited Oscar was to pander the Latino vote. Yeah. And Oscar realizes it too. He has a talking head. And Oscar was so funny when he delivered this talking head. I want to read it to you. He has a talking head, and Oscar was so funny when he delivered this talking head. I want to read it to you. He says, maybe I should be insulted that he only invited me here to be his token Mexican friend, but he could have invited any number of Hispanics that he knows. His gardener, Rogelio, or he could have invited Rogelio, but he chose me. invited, Rogelio. But he chose me. Rogelio's Malaysian. That son of a bitch is Malaysian. I know. It's so funny the way he does it. We're going to go back to Daryl and Jim's
我们到底在讲哪一集？好吧，这里，我找到了。我找到了。我们会发现，罗伯特邀请奥斯卡的唯一原因就是为了迎合拉丁裔选民。对。而且奥斯卡自己也意识到了。他有一段独白。奥斯卡在发表这段独白时太搞笑了。我想读给你们听。他有一段独白，奥斯卡在发表这段独白时太搞笑了。我想读给你们听。他说，也许我应该感到被羞辱，因为他邀请我来只是为了当他的美籍墨西哥人吉祥物，但他本来可以邀请他认识的任何数量的西班牙裔。他的园丁罗赫里奥，或者他本可以邀请罗赫里奥，但他偏偏选中了我。邀请了罗赫里奥。但他偏偏选中了我。罗赫里奥是马来西亚人。那个混蛋是马来西亚人。我知道。他演这段的方式太搞笑了。我们现在切回达里尔和吉姆的
apartment now. Yeah. This is the scene that Lee said they couldn't get through. Daryl has his cooler. Yes. His travel cooler. Yes. This travel cooler. And, you know, it seems like they're going to make up. You know, it seems like they're going to come into agreement. They're going to put this whole issue to rest. And then that is when Daryl realizes that Jim deleted
公寓。对。这就是利说过他们拍不下去的那场戏。达里尔拿着他的冷藏箱。对。他的旅行冷藏箱。对。这个旅行冷藏箱，你知道，看起来他们要言归于好了。你知道，看起来他们要达成一致了。他们要把这整件事彻底抛诸脑后了。然后就在那时，达里尔发现吉姆删掉了
all his Tavis Smiley episodes. Yeah. I have an observation from this scene. I have two observations. OK. Number one, Jim John is eating baby carrots. I have an observation from this scene. I have two observations. Okay. Number one, Jim John is eating baby carrots. He loves his baby carrots. He has a sandwich on his plate, but the only thing he's eating is baby carrots.
他所有的塔维斯·斯迈利节目。对。我对这场戏有个观察。我有两个观察。好的。第一，吉姆·约翰在吃小胡萝卜。我对这场戏有个观察。我有两个观察。好的。第一，吉姆·约翰在吃小胡萝卜。他太爱吃小胡萝卜了。他盘子里有个三明治，但他唯一在吃的就是小胡萝卜。
Number two, in this back and forth, Jim says, are you really telling me that if I needed some flour, I couldn't take some of your flour? He's like, it's a five pound bag of flour, Dar some flour, I couldn't take some of your flour? He's like, it's a five pound bag of flour, Darryl. I can't have some. And then Darryl says, what do you need flour for, Jim? Yeah, you're making bread.
第二，在这段你来我往的对话中，吉姆说，你真的在告诉我，如果我需要一些面粉，我就不能拿你的一些面粉吗？他说，达里尔，那可是一大袋五磅重的面粉。一些面粉，我就不能拿你的一些面粉吗？他说，达里尔，那可是一大袋五磅重的面粉。难道我都不能拿一点吗？然后达里尔说，吉姆，你要面粉干什么？对，你这是在做面包。
Okay, my question is, what does Darryl need a five pound bag of flour for? That is bread making amounts of flour. I'm just gonna say it. I don't think you have five pounds of flour unless you're making bread. Maybe Darryl makes bread. Or homemade pizza dough.
好吧，我的问题是，达里尔要一整袋五磅重的面粉干什么？这绝对是做面包级别的面粉用量。我就直说了吧。我觉得除非你在做面包，否则你根本不会买五磅面粉。也许达里尔会做面包。或者自制披萨面团。
He's making something. With a lot of flour. Well, this scene would actually set up more tension. There was another deleted scene where Jim and Darryl, they're kind of at their wits end, they're at athlead, and they call Toby to help them problem solve their conflict. And Toby is clearly so happy to be of service, but he's so boring that I think this is the beginning
他在做什么东西。需要大量的面粉。好吧，这场戏其实原本会引发更多的冲突。还有另一个被删掉的片段，吉姆和达里尔，他们简直黔驴技穷了，在Athlead公司工作，于是他们打电话给托比，请他帮忙解决他们之间的矛盾。而托比显然非常乐意效劳，但他实在太无聊了，我觉得这就是吉姆和达里尔
of the bridge of Jim and Daryl making up. Because they put him on speakerphone and they actually ultimately just walk away because he's so boring. Here, let's hear it. So it started at home and now it's bleeding into work. Do you have any thoughts? I really appreciate you guys coming to me with this conflict.
重修旧好的序幕。因为他们把他按成了免提，最后干脆直接走开了，因为他太无聊了。来，我们听听看。所以这事是从家里开始的，现在已经蔓延到工作上了。你们有什么想法吗？我非常感谢你们能带着这个矛盾来找我。
Okay, I'm going to put you through a series of exercises. I want you each to write down 12 things you like about the other and 12 things you dislike. This is a mistake. In my head, he was such an asset. I don't know where that came from. I'm up with the 12 likes first and then go to your dislikes but I recommend building both lists simultaneously. An interesting thing you'll find is that sometimes the likes and dislikes are the same thing. I'm just gonna get a hammer I'm sorry, too I'll get my own t-bow
好吧，我要让你们做一系列练习。我要你们每个人写下对方身上的12个优点，以及12个缺点。这是一个错误。在我的想象中，他本该是个得力帮手的。我不知道那想法是从哪来的。我先列出12个优点，然后再列缺点，但我建议同时列出这两份清单。你会发现一个有趣的事实，有时优点和缺点其实是同一回事。我去找个锤子，抱歉，我也，我去找我自己的TiVo。
That's what I'm talking about. Okay pencils down now. Let's trade lists. Whoever wants to start the discussion. Just go ahead Don't ask it I can wait They both hit mute and her like, this is horrible. And then Jim's like, look, I'll just get a hamper. You heard Daryl. Daryl's like, I'll get TiVo. And then they just walk away and leave Toby on speakerphone. Oh my gosh.
就是这样。好了，笔放下。现在交换清单。谁想带头发起讨论。直接开始吧，别问了，我可以等。他们俩都按了静音，心想，这太可怕了。然后吉姆就说，听着，我去拿个洗衣篮。你听见达里尔说的了吧。达里尔说，我去拿TiVo。然后他们就直接走开，把托比晾在免提电话那头。哦，天哪。
That's really funny. That is really funny. So Jim and Daryl have called Toby for help. Pam is going to call Daryl for help. There's a lot of phone calls in this episode. And they find out that the thing that Frank cherishes is his truck. Yeah, so now they know how to get back at him.
太搞笑了。真的太搞笑了。所以吉姆和达里尔打电话找托比帮忙。潘将打电话找达里尔帮忙。这一集里有好多电话。然后他们发现弗兰克最珍视的东西是他的卡车。对，所以现在他们知道怎么报复他了。
They are going to paint graffiti on Frank's truck. Dwight is going to paint Pam's mural on the truck's butt. On the tailgate, yeah. Because Frank painted butts on Pam's mural on the truck's butt. On the tailgate, yeah. Cause Frank painted butts on Pam's mural. Pam has made quite the drawing down the side of the car. It's like a kind of a blob looking dude that looks like Frank a little bit and he's farting. Yes, and he has big saggy lady boobs.
他们要在弗兰克的卡车上喷涂涂鸦。德怀特要在卡车屁股上把潘的壁画喷上去。在后挡板上，对。因为弗兰克在潘的壁画屁股上画了屁股。在后挡板上，对。因为弗兰克在潘的壁画上画了屁股。潘在车身侧面画了一幅相当精彩的画。那是一个看起来有点像Blob的家伙，有点像弗兰克，而且他还在放屁。对，他还有一对巨大的下垂女性乳房。
And Dwight's like, I love it, now draw a penis on it. We got a fan question from Bernice C in in Upland, California, who said, please tell us everything that Standards and Practices had to say about the pictures on the truck. Well, thanks to Steve Burge, as we know, Standards and Practices said, quote, the saggy lady boobs, unquote, on the side of the truck should not be lifelike in appearance. That was their note. Okay. So no lifelike butts and no lifelike saggy lady boobs.
然后德怀特说，我太喜欢了，现在在上面画个阴茎吧。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州乌普兰市的伯尼斯·C的粉丝提问，她说，请把审查部门（Standards and Practices）对卡车上画作的所有评价都告诉我们。好吧，多亏了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，如我们所知，审查部门表示，引述一下，“车身侧面下垂的女性乳房”，未引述，其外观不应该过于逼真。这就是他们的意见。好吧。所以不能有逼真的屁股，也不能有逼真的下垂女性乳房。
You know, all of this graffiti on the truck is actually making Pam feel better. And Dwight says, you know, I like hanging out with a vengeful bitch. And I love that Pam's like, you miss Angela, don't you? Oh yeah, I know. I love that Pam's like, you miss Angela, don't you? Oh yeah, I know. Well, now we're gonna have this big fight.
你知道，卡车上的这些涂鸦实际上让潘感觉好多了。德怀特说，你知道，我喜欢跟一个复仇心切的恶毒女人一起鬼混。我太喜欢潘的回应了，她说，你想念安吉拉了，对吧？哦，对，我懂。我太喜欢潘的回应了，她说，你想念安吉拉了，对吧？哦，对，我懂。好吧，现在我们要迎来这场大战了。
Oh my goodness. Pam is giving a quite gloating talking head. She's very pleased with herself. She does reveal that this is water-based paint. Of course, Frank doesn't know that. She got back at Frank the best way with her art. Yeah, she used her art as a weapon. Frank is gonna come charging out of the building,
哦，天哪。潘发了一段极其幸灾乐祸的独白。她对自己的所作所为非常满意。她透露这其实是水性漆。当然，弗兰克并不知道这一点。她用自己的艺术以最好的方式报复了弗兰克。对，她把艺术当作了武器。弗兰克气势汹汹地冲出大楼，
yelling at Pam. He's like, that's a $40,000 truck. Yeah, and he's scary. So Brian the boom guy, as Lee mentioned, is gonna step in, he's gonna hit Frank in the face with his boom pole then very gently lay his equipment down. And then a full-on scuffle breaks out. Two members of our crew made it into this scene, our first AD Rusty Mahmood
冲着潘大喊大叫。他说，那可是辆价值4万美元的卡车。对，而且他很吓人。所以正如利所提到的，摄影师布赖恩介入了，他用他的收音杆狠狠砸了弗兰克的脸，然后非常轻柔地把设备放下。接着爆发了一场全面的混战。我们剧组有两名成员参演了这场戏，我们的第一副导演拉斯蒂·马哈茂德
and our real boom operator Nick Carbone. Yes! We had a fan question from Hannah H in Cleveland, Ohio who said, was it frightening during that scene where Pam is almost attacked? It startles me every time. Was there a safety meeting perhaps? Oh, Hannah, we had a whole afternoon of choreography for this scene with Brett Jones, our stunt coordinator. It was a fully choreographed fight. But I will tell you, when I watch it, it looks very real.
和我们的实地收音师尼克·卡博内。太棒了！我们收到了来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰市的汉娜·H的粉丝提问，她说，潘差点遇袭的那场戏真的很吓人吗？每次看我都吓一跳。当时是不是开过安全会议？哦，汉娜，我们为这场戏和特技协调员布雷特·琼斯一起排练了整整一个下午的动作设计。这是一场经过完全编排的打斗戏。但我得告诉你，当我看着它时，它看起来非常真实。
It does. It looks very in the moment. So I thought they did a great job with that. They really did. Well, because he was stepping in, Brian got fired. Yeah. We have a scene where he's gathering his things to leave in that closet behind the door. We talked about that with Lee? Mm-hmm.
确实如此。看起来非常即兴自然。所以我认为他们这场戏拍得太棒了。真的太棒了。好吧，因为他插手了，布赖恩被解雇了。对。我们有一场戏，他正在那个门后的壁橱里收拾东西准备离开。我们跟利讨论过这个吗？嗯哼。
And Pam says to him, you know, I'll go talk with the producers. I'm so sorry. And that he doesn't deserve to be fired for just protecting her. Mm-hmm. Brian's gonna say, you know, I knew what I was doing, and I'm just happy they fired Frank as well.
潘对他说，你知道的，我会去跟制片人谈谈的。我很抱歉。他不应该仅仅因为保护了她而被解雇。嗯哼。布赖恩说，你知道的，我知道自己在做什么，而且我也很高兴弗兰克也被开除了。
And he's like, look, I don't wanna sort of put myself in a place where I shouldn't be. But if you ever need me, just call me and I'll be there. Well, now here's one of my questions. All of this upset people so much. But has Brian like really, has he stepped over the line in any way that Pam would have noticed? So far, I think not.
然后他说，听着，我不想把自己置于不该呆的位置。但如果你需要我，随时打电话给我，我都会在。好吧，现在我的问题来了。所有这些让大家如此心烦意乱。但布赖恩真的，他有没有做出任何会让潘察觉到的越轨举止？到目前为止，我觉得没有。
If Pam and Jim are friends with Brian and Alyssa, like I'm imagining, right? I'm off on a set, and let's say for whatever reason, Josh is there and I'm getting picked on or I break down crying. Josh would step in for you. Josh would and leave to you. Of course. Right? They would make sure we were okay.
如果潘和吉姆跟布赖恩和阿莉莎是好朋友，就像我想象的那样，对吧？我在片场，比方说，由于某种原因，乔希也在，然后我被人找麻烦了或者崩溃大哭。乔希会为你出头的。乔希会的，而且会为了你挺身而出。当然。对吧？他们会确保我们没事的。
The only hint that we've been given as an audience that Brian isn't maybe on the quote up and up is that one shot of him kind of smiling at Pam. And the boop on the head. And the boop on the head. You're right. Mm-hmm. You're right.
作为观众，我们得到的唯一暗示，即布赖恩可能并非完全“堂堂正正”的镜头，就是他冲着潘微笑的那一个特写。还有敲头。还有敲头。你说得对。嗯哼。你说得对。
Those two things felt a little flirty. Uh-huh. Yeah. OK. Well, I have to share something really quickly that made me laugh that our writer Owen shared with us, because I agree. I called this hot take. Brian is too hot.
那两件事确实让人感觉有点调情。嗯哼。好吧。好吧，我得赶紧分享一件把我逗乐的事，这是我们的编剧欧文分享给我们的，因为我举双手赞成。我管这叫惊人热评：布赖恩长得太帅了。
Okay. Owen wrote this. This is not even strictly about the episode, just a season nine take that I want to get off my chest. And then in all caps, he wrote, Brian was too handsome. A bunch of us in the writer's room felt it was counterproductive to make the boom guy attractive to the degree that we could sell romantic drama.
好的。欧文写了这段。这甚至严格来说不是关于这一集的，只是我一直想吐露的一个关于第九季的看法。然后他用全大写字母写道：布莱恩太帅了。编剧室里的很多人都觉得，把收音师塑造得具有某种程度的吸引力，以至于能让我们推销浪漫剧情，这会适得其反。
It was in this other guy liking Pam, not in Pam liking him back. So several of us were pushing for a schlubbier actor for the role of Brian. In parentheses he put, I will protect my fellow schlubs by not listing their names. Instead we got Chris Diamantopoulos,
问题在于这个其他人喜欢帕姆，而不是帕姆反过来喜欢他。所以我们当中的好几个人都在极力主张为布莱恩这个角色找一个外形更普通、更邋遢的演员。他在括号里写道：我会通过不列出他们的名字来保护我的同行们。相反，我们得到了克里斯·迪亚曼托普洛斯，
great actor, fantastic actor, disqualifyingly hot. And then we made it much worse by putting him in a tight t-shirt that highlighted his muscles. As a wrestling fan, I'm all for dudes being jacked, but this was problematic jackness. In retrospect, it was too late in the game for us to tease Pam ending up with someone else, and the audience could tell we didn't really mean it,
一个伟大的演员，杰出的演员，帅得让人没话说。然后我们给他穿上一件凸显他肌肉的紧身T恤，让情况变得更糟了。作为一个摔角迷，我完全支持硬汉肌肉男，但这是一种有问题的肌肉男。事后看来，现在为时已晚，我们无法再暗示帕姆会和别人在一起，观众一眼就能看出我们并不是认真的，
so they rejected it. Bryan's attractiveness was what made it really feel like a tease. Team Shlubby Brian for life. It's very funny that he said that because I did notice that he was in long sleeves for this whole episode. But it was cold out this week. It was colder out this week, but I'm sure what we didn't need were his bulging muscles fighting Frank or his bulging muscles as Pam was like,
所以他们拒绝接受。布莱恩的迷人之处正是让这一切真正感觉像是一个恶作剧的原因。永远支持普通版布莱恩。他说这话太搞笑了，因为我确实注意到他在这一整集里都穿着长袖。不过这周外面很冷。这周外面更冷，但我确信我们不需要的是他跟弗兰克打架时隆起的肌肉，或者是当帕姆说时他那隆起的肌肉，
I'm so sorry you got fired. And he's like, you can count on me anytime. So I'll be interested to see if we cover up his muscles from now on. But we did note, oh my gosh, this guy is an amazing shape. The scene you were talking about where he doesn't realize that he's smiling, watching Pam, and he's holding the boom. He's in a tight short-sleeved t-shirt. Well, I haven't had a chance to tell my audition stories yet, but I remember the slew of Schlubby Brian's. And I will tell you that the other side of that argument was that a lot of the schlubs reminded us too much of Jim. And it seemed a little bit like you had this sort of like,
我很遗憾你被解雇了。而他说，你随时可以指望我。所以我会很有兴趣看看从现在开始我们是否会把他的肌肉遮掩起来。但我们确实注意到，天哪，这家伙的身材太棒了。你刚才说的那场戏里，他没意识到自己在微笑，看着帕姆，还拿着收音杆。他穿着一件紧身的短袖T恤。好吧，我还没机会讲我的试镜故事，但我记得有一大群普普通通的布莱恩。而且我得告诉你们，那个论点的另一面是，许多普普通通的演员让我们想起了太多吉姆。而且这看起来有点像你有一种类似，
aw shucks, every man falling for Pam. And it seemed like the argument was, Pam is attracted to the aw shucks, every man. And it would be worse to cast that guy as Brian. That it was better to cast this person who looked nothing like Jim and seemed nothing like Jim. Because Pam would be less likely to be attracted to him. Although he does, I don't know, she was attracted to Roy. He was a big beefy guy, right?
啊，见鬼，每个男人都爱上了帕姆。而且似乎争论的焦点是，帕姆被这种天真无邪、所有男人都会喜欢的特质所吸引。把那个家伙选为布莱恩会更糟糕。最好是选一个长得一点也不像吉姆、看起来也一点也不像吉姆的人。因为帕姆不太可能会被他吸引。尽管他确实，我不知道，她被罗伊吸引了。他是个身材魁梧的大块头，对吧？
Why are you laughing? Oh man, because I just, I just imagined John hearing this, but if I'm John and you're like, you know what, because he, he would have been too much like schlubby John Krasinski. Listen, John has moved from the Shlubby Basket to the Muscle Basket, okay? It's fine, but he did start in a Shlubby Basket, he did. John, I'm sorry your first basket didn't have a six pack. It didn't! Oh my gosh.
你笑什么？哦天哪，因为我只是，我只是想象约翰听到这话的情景，但如果我是约翰而你却说，你知道吗，因为他，他会太像那个普通的约翰·卡拉辛斯基了。听着，约翰已经从普通篮子移到了肌肉篮子，好吧？没关系，但他确实是从普通篮子开始的，确实。约翰，我很抱歉你的第一个篮子没有六块腹肌。它确实没有！哦天哪。
It didn't. John, we love you, okay? We love you. I am not participating in this basket conversation. You know what? I'm out of it. Listen, I started in the ingenue basket. Now I'm in menopause basket and everything that goes with it.
它确实没有。约翰，我们爱你，好吧？我们爱你。我不参与这个关于篮子的对话。你知道吗？我不干了。听着，我从纯情少女篮开始。现在我进入了更年期篮，以及与之俱来的一切。
Do not sell yourself short. You are in periomenopause basket. There's a basket between. There is. I'm in... It's a sexy periomenopause basket. Yeah. Put that in your womeniomenopause basket. Yeah. Put that in your women's journal.
不要看低自己。你处于围绝经期篮。中间还有一个篮子。确实有。我处于……这是一个性感的围绝经期篮。是的。把它放进你的女性围绝经期篮里。是的。把它放进你的女性杂志里。
I'm in it. What basket are we in now? We're not in any basket. We have skipped some scenes in the Lipton house that we need to go back to. Oh, the whole photo op. Yes. This is the photo op that we talked about with Lee where I just broke. I just completely started laughing because Oscar and I were improvising. And then this is going to lead to all of us leaving the party. We're saying our goodbyes. Oh, this scene is so good with Kevin.
我进去了。我们现在在哪个篮子里？我们不在任何篮子里。我们跳过了利普顿家的一些场景，我们需要回去。哦，整个拍照环节。是的。这就是我们和李谈论过的那个拍照环节，当时我直接笑场了。我完全开始大笑，因为奥斯卡和我在即兴表演。然后这将导致我们所有人离开派对。我们在道别。哦，凯文这场戏太棒了。
I know. And Angela apologizes to Robert for the conflict in the photo op. She says it was my fault. Kevin comes in and says, Robert, thank you for the food, but you suck. Yeah, he said these two people care about you and you're just using them. But again, the food was great.
我知道。安吉拉为拍照环节中的冲突向罗伯特道歉。她说那是我的错。凯文走进来对罗伯特说，谢谢你的食物，但你真烂。是的，他说这两个人在乎你，而你只是在利用他们。不过话说回来，食物真棒。
Oscar and Angela follow Kevin out. Angela has a little smile on her face that Kevin stood up for her. There was this extended driving scene that Lee talked about. It starts with a Kevin talking head and then ends with the three of us in the car. And I'd love for you guys to hear it. I've sat next to Oscar and Angela for 14 years. They're my people.
奥斯卡和安吉拉跟着凯文走了出去。安吉拉脸上带着一丝微笑，因为凯文为她挺身而出。李谈到的那场长时间的开车戏就是这个。它以凯文的独白开始，然后以我们三个人在车里结束。我很想让你们听听。我坐在奥斯卡和安吉拉旁边14年了。他们是我的人。
If you just go by distance, they're my best friends. I don't know why you go by distance though, I guess. Thanks for getting me all this stuff, Ange. We had way too many appetizers anyway. I don't know who did the ordering. How hard is it to buy for forty? Some people are just terrible at math. It's embarrassing. It is. Totally. So they bond over this moment where people are bad at math. I also love that Kevin's like these are my people. You know what? It's that thing that breaks my
如果你只按距离算，他们是我最好的朋友。不过我不知道你为什么要按距离算，我猜。谢谢你给我买这么多东西，安吉。我们点的前菜本来就太多了。我不知道是谁点的。给四十个人买东西有多难？有些人数学简直烂到家了。真尴尬。确实。完全同意。所以他们因为人们数学不好这个时刻而产生了共鸣。我也很喜欢凯文说这些人是我的人。你知道吗？就是那种让我
heart that Brian Baumgartner does so well as Kevin when he gets that little quiver in his voice. Yeah. And he gets like vulnerable. Yes. So sweet. Really sweet. And that scene was so fun to do. Well, Owen Ellickson said that he loved that scene, Angela, when we asked him like what were some of your favorite moments. He said the three of you guys driving back from the party bonding over math mistakes. He said you guys played it beautifully, and I hope that scene makes the light of day at
心碎的感觉，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳饰演凯文时做得非常好，当他的声音开始微微颤抖时。是的。而且他变得很脆弱。是的。太甜了。真的很甜。拍那场戏太有趣了。嗯，欧文·埃利克森说他很喜欢那场戏，安吉拉，当我们问他你最喜欢的时刻有哪些时。他说你们三个人从派对开车回来，因数学错误而产生共鸣。他说你们演得太精彩了，我希望那场戏能见天日
some point. Aw, thanks, Owen. Mm-hmm. Well, this scene is going to end with a tag. Jim and Daryl's very clean apartment. And guess what? What? It's actually not how the shooting draft ended.
某个时刻。哦，谢谢，欧文。嗯哼。好吧，这场戏将以一个片尾彩蛋结束。吉姆和达尔非常干净的公寓。你猜怎么着？什么？其实拍摄初稿并不是这样结束的。
So you describe how it ended when it aired, and I will share the final moment of the shooting draft ended. So you describe how it ended when it aired, and I will share the final moment of the shooting draft. Okay. Well, Jim and Darryl are playing video games. Darryl finishes the soda and he crumples the can and throws it on the floor. And Jim says, how did that feel? Did it feel good? And Darryl's like, it felt really good. And then if you want to know how John Krasinski laughs in real life, it is this laugh right here. He got so tickled. That is pure JK.
所以你描述一下播出时它是怎么结束的，我会分享拍摄初稿的最后时刻。所以你描述一下播出时它是怎么结束的，我会分享拍摄初稿的最后时刻。好的。好吧，吉姆和达尔在玩电子游戏。达尔喝完苏打水，把易拉罐揉成一团扔在地板上。吉姆说，感觉怎么样？感觉好吗？达尔说，感觉真的很棒。然后如果你想知道约翰·卡拉辛斯基在现实生活中是怎么笑的，就是这个笑声。他笑得太开心了。那是纯粹的JK。
Well, this is how the episode ended in the shooting draft. And of course, once I read it to you, you'll understand why they decided not to end this way. Okay. Already with the uproar about Brian, the boom guy. Oh my gosh, is this something I've forgotten? Probably, but we did read it and it was in the shooting draft. So that means they did shoot it. It would have ended with a Brian talking head after his scuffle.
好吧，这就是这一集在拍摄初稿中的结局。当然，一旦我读给你听，你就会明白为什么他们决定不这样收尾了。好吧。关于收音师布莱恩的喧嚣已经够多了。哦天哪，这是我忘掉的事吗？可能吧，但我们确实读过，而且它就在拍摄初稿里。这意味着他们确实拍了。它本应该以布莱恩在冲突后的独白结束。
Brian talking head outside. Brian's a little roughed up. Brian says to the camera operator, fine, okay. He turns to the documentarian and sighs. I'm Brian Whittle. I was the boom mic operator on this documentary until about three minutes ago when they fired me. I don't regret stepping in.
布莱恩在室外的独白。布莱恩有点狼狈。布莱恩对摄像师说，行，好吧。他转向纪录片制作人并叹了口气。我是布莱恩·惠特尔。我是这部纪录片里的收音师，直到大约三分钟前他们把我解雇了。我不后悔介入。
Nobody messes with Pam. Pam's my buddy. I spent nine years recording her voice. I followed her to art school in New York. Hell, if it wasn't for those no-interfere agreements we signed, I would have… whatever. It's fine. Then he looks to the boom guy. Hold it higher. Trust the mic. Right there. See? Perfect. Oh no. Yeah. That was in the shooting draft. I think I remember that now. Yeah. If it wasn't for those don't interfere agreements, I would have dot dot dot maybe whatever. You know what? That sounds like five dots to me. Dot dot dot dot dot. Yeah.
没人能惹帕姆。帕姆是我的好朋友。我花了九年时间录制她的声音。我跟着她去了纽约的艺术学校。见鬼，要不是我们签了那些不干涉协议，我本会……随便吧。没关系。然后他看着收音师。举高点。相信话筒。就在那儿。看到了吗？完美。哦，不。是的。那在拍摄初稿里。我想我现在记起来了。是的。要不是那些不干涉协议，我本会点点点，也许随便吧。你知道吗？在我听来这有五个点。点点点点点。是的。
Well, there you have it everybody. That was vandalism. I think we have some big thank yous to shout out. Yes, a big thank you to my husband, Lee Kirk, for coming into the studio today and talking with us. Yes, and also to Owen Ellickson, our writer, who was so gracious in answering our fan questions. Yes, Owen is currently working on St. Dennis Medical. It's an upcoming NBC comedy from the office's own Justin Spitzer. But he'd also like to give a shout out to Chocolate Milk,
好吧，大家都看到了。那是破坏公物。我想我们要大声感谢一些人。是的，非常感谢我的丈夫李·柯克今天来到工作室和我们聊天。是的，还有我们的编剧欧文·埃利克森，他非常亲切地回答了粉丝的问题。是的，欧文目前正在创作《圣丹尼斯医疗》。这是NBC即将推出的一部喜剧，由《办公室》自己的杰斯汀·斯皮策打造。但他还想对巧克力奶表示感谢，
which he says is, quote, an excellent drink that deserves more respect than adults give it, end quote. So funny. And of course, a thank you to Steve Burgess and to all of you for your excellent questions this week. Yes, and to Josh for making us Madeline's. Yeah. We had some good treats today.
他称其为，引述一下，一种绝佳的饮料，值得比成年人给予它更多的尊重，引述结束。太搞笑了。当然，还要感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯以及本周提出精彩问题的你们所有人。是的，还要感谢乔什给我们做了玛德琳蛋糕。是的。我们今天吃到了很好的点心。
We hope you guys have a great week and we just love you and love doing this and we'll see you next week. With an update on landlines. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望大家度过美好的一周，我们只是爱你们并且热爱做这件事，我们下周见。会有关于座机的最新消息。到时候见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwulf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的副制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉特顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。